Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Pisa Studio ist rausgekommen, hat rausgefunden, dass fünfzig Prozent der Jugendlichen Fakten und Meinungen nicht unterscheiden können.
Meinst du vielleicht.
Buchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertzweiundneunzig vom sechsten Mai zwanzigeinundzwanzig eurer Faktenbasis und eure Meinungsbastion in einem.
Bei uns ist es ja genau, bei uns ist es sind Meinungen und Fakten ja eins.
Du meinst so, was unsere Meinung ist? Das ist einfach mal Fakt.
So
Ja, das da, ja, so war das.
Wir machen, wir machen das für euch schon, wir klären das schon für euch, ja? Das machen wir vorher, das ist alles Arbeit, die wir euch, aber uns muss man auch nicht lesen, kann man aber, Tim wird ja nicht müde, zu betonen, dass die Transkriptionsfunktion immer besser wird.
Das stimmt. Da wird fließt gerade noch viel äh Arbeit rein und bin auch ganz zuversichtlich, bald äh vielleicht nicht das ganze Archiv, aber auch zumindest weitgehend äh das Archiv hier,
bekommen zu haben. Aber das ist wirklich interessant. Also die meinen also genau heißt es, weniger als die Hälfte der.
Weißt du, was das heißt.
Zehnjährigen Schülerinnen und Schüler nicht mehr in der Lage, beim Lesen Fakten von Meinungen zu unterscheiden.
Und der ist doch super. Und weißt du, was das Problem ist, Tim? Ich meine, warum das mit der Hälfte so problematisch ist, ne? Die sind die die sind die Mehrheit dann. Das heißt, es wird Ideocrassy.
Direkt mehrere Beispiele für.
Ja, ich meine, ist der das überhaupt klar, dass wirklich die Hälfte der Leute einen IQ unter einhundert hat? Na.
Irrtum, das wird völlig klar. Weißt du auch, wieso? Okay, aber dann sollen wir das kurz noch erklären?
Weiß nicht, muss man das erklären?
Ja, muss man kurz erklären. Ähm,
Der der IQ ist ein äh normierter Wert. Es ist eigentlich eine Gausch äh Glockenkurve, hat also einen Mittelwert und eine Standardabweichung
und normalerweise, wenn man solche Werte nimmt, also in der Statistik, wenn man sauber arbeitet, dann wenn man vereinheitlicht arbeitet, dann nimmt man einfach Z-Standardisierte Werte, also Mittelwert, null Standardabweichung eins. Und das heißt
dass ähm quasi achtundsechzig Komma irgendwas Prozent quasi sich innerhalb der Standardabweichungen,
um den Mittelwert bewegen. Und das ist quasi dann der Normbereich in Hass. In jeder äh in jeder Richtung nochmal fünfzehn Prozent, die dann quasi in die Extreme gehen.
Und wenn du eine zstschneideisierte Werte hast, kannst du die umbauen auf äh jede andere Normierung und beim IQ,
ist das ähm Mittelwert einhundert und Standardabweichungen fünfzehn und das hat man einfach so gemacht, damit man Eltern nicht erklären muss, dass das Kind einen negativen Intelligenzkonzerten hat. Ja, ist also rein kommunikativer.
Hm? Und äh von fünfundachtzig bis hundertfünfzehn ist also einfach der Normalbereich und der ähm.
Ja, die besonderen Bereiche, also starke äh äh starke Intelligenz oder besonders starke Intelligenzminderung, wären dann ebenso bei bei zwei Standardabweichungen äh setzt man die dann,
üblicherweise an. Gibt's unterschiedliche äh Definitionen, aber ähm.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, auch mit dem IQ von hundertzehn, kriegt man die Kurve noch nicht so richtig.
Nee, aber da aber mit den Fakten und den Meinungen, das auseinanderzuhalten, das könnte da noch schwierig sein. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich unbedingt was mit Intelligenz zu tun hat, weil ich denke, da gibt's auch noch diverse kulturelle Faktoren und letztlich sind wir wahrscheinlich auch alle daran schuld.
Nicht durch das ganze äh mediale äh Gewitter und die Komplexität unserer Gesellschaft et cetera und äh die Qualität unserer Bildung. Und was nicht alles noch herangezogen werden
kann. Irgendein Grund muss es ja haben.
Also ich würde mich jetzt zu spontan als Psychologe äh würde ich sagen, sicherlich wird es eine äh starke Korrelation mit dem IQ geben.
Ähm bei der Fähigkeit oder der Kompetenzmeinungen von Fakten zu unterscheiden,
würde aber grundsätzlich erstmal davon ausgehen, dass wie jeder andere Koalition auch, die nicht eins ist und das ist sicherlich auch Kinder mit überdurchschnittlichem IQ gibt
diese Kompetenz nicht haben. Und äh Kinder mitunter durchschnittlichem IQ gibt, die diese Kompetenz nicht haben,
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das äh dass der IQ wie alles ist es ist es sicherlich stark korreliert mit IQ aber nicht.
Okay, wollte ich damit auch überhaupt nicht äh sagen. Sicherlich gibt's hier auch noch so eine Qualität der sozialen Kompetenz, beziehungsweise einfach der allgemeinen Bedingungen. Also ich könnte mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, dass.
Ganz gut dran sind.
Also wenn sie gut dran sind, haben sie es auf jeden Fall nicht bei uns gelernt. Das muss man.
Wir sind nicht schuld!
Dass das mal klar ist.
Ah ja. Okay, ein kleiner Exkurs in äh in die Idiokratie. Ähm,
Ich denke, äh wir haben ja auch die ersten Anzeichen, die also es ist ja nicht unbedingt so, als wäre es bei Erwachsenen besser, ne. Das äh muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Ähm.
Stimmt.
Und in in Südthüringen wurde jetzt Hans-Georg Maaßen als CDU-Bundeskandidat.
Hingestellt. Wir hatten das ja hier schon davor gewarnt, dass dieses Risiko besteht.
Also Kandidat für den Bundestag.
Ja
Wurde zwanzig, äh der war von zwanzig zwölf bis zwanzig achtzehn Präsident des Bundesverfassungsschutzes äh ist wegen seiner Kontakte zur AfD und zur äh zu irgendwelchen nicht äh durch Fakt.
Also ja genau, der hat auch Probleme mit der Unterscheidung von Fakten und Meinungen. Der hat sich ja damals irgendwie zu fremdenfeindlichen äh Ausschreitungen in Chemnitz äh äh sage ich mal faktenfremd und meinungsschwer geäußert,
Und äh.
Auch seitdem nicht wirklich das Maul gehalten.
Man muss natürlich auch äh die CDU in Thüringen verstehen, sie sind ja gerade ihres Handelnbundeskandidaten Bundestagskandidaten verlustig geworden, weil der ja leider im Rahmen dieses Massenskandals irgendwie geflogen ist.
Ja. Die haben halt nur korrupte und rechtsradikal.
Ist ja was anderes haben wir jetzt nicht. Country und Western sozusagen.
Unglaublich, es ist eine Katastrophe. Ich meine, dass dieser Mann wirklich, sage ich mal, nicht.
Also, dass dieser Mann sich allenfalls noch so mit den spitzen Zehen auf dem Boden der Verfassung hält, ne? Das ist, glaube ich, äh hinlänglich bekannt. Und dass der wirklich.
Also das ist ein ganz äh also.
Der ehemalige Chef des Verfassungsschutzes ist wirklich etwas. Das geht echt überhaupt nicht mehr. Immerhin ist der ein oder andere CDU ähm
ein oder andere CDU-Mitglied in der Folge sogar auch ausgetreten, sowas finde ich ja dann doch ganz bemerkenswert auf jeden Fall, da hat die CDU definitiv
Ja, ein ein mindestens ein Problem der CDU hat eine Menge Probleme, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, noch ein ein weiteres, was jetzt hinzugekommen ist.
Ich möchte nur erinnern, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, in welcher Sendung, aber du findest das mit den Transkripten bestimmt heraus, dass ich es damals gesagt habe, dass dieser Mann
wenn, dass er, wenn er jetzt da rausfliegt und sich und eine politische Zukunft sucht, dass der problematisch wird
So, dass der in der, dass der früher oder später zur AfD überläuft, ähm wahrscheinlich geht er jetzt auf den CDU Ticket in Bundestag und wird sich dann ähm,
Was weiß ich, weil irgendein Geflüchteter nicht abgeschoben äh wurde äh von der Fraktion trennen oder so. Das ist äh das ist ein.
Da gibt's, glaube ich, keine keine Zweifel an an dessen äh politischer Heimat mehr. Das muss man, glaube ich, sagen.
Zweifel der politischen Heimat sind auch bei alles dichtmachen inzwischen äh glaube ich beseitigt Tim, oder?
Mach ganz so den Eindruck, dass äh die die Truppe beileibe nicht nur so
äh bürgerlich ist, wie sie bisher immer getan hat, sondern, und, und, das ist auch alles nicht so ein zufälliges Konglomerat von Meinungsäußerungen war von irgendwie dahergelaufenen, unschuldigen Tatort äh Kommissaren, sondern dass das schon doch ein bisschen mehr Planung und Struktur hat, da sicherlich der eine oder der andere auch
etwas überfahren wurde dort von den Kollegen, sich aber trotzdem mal alle fragen müssen, was eigentlich so ausschlaggebend ist für sie, um an so einer Aktion teilzunehmen
in der andere ihnen die Texte vorgeben, die sie dann in Kameras einlesen, um sich irgendwie in so einer Situation zur politischen Gesamtsituation zu äußern, schon ein bisschen fragwürdig
Aber noch sehr viel fragwürdiger sind halt die Leute, die dann offenbar dieses ganze Projekt angetrieben haben, denn da sind so diverse Artikel erschienen, die eine,
ziemlich in die äh sowohl zu den Querdenkerischen Thesen als auch diesen dieser neuen Querdenker Partei,
offen gelegt haben, äh wo man schon ein wenig ins Grübeln kommen könnte.
Du meinst die Basis, ne?
Die Basis.
Da gibt's sehr schöne äh,
sehr schöne Artikel auf äh Anon Leaks dot net, ja? Äh die haben ja seit einiger Zeit die Operation Tinnvoll, optinvoll laufen und äh setzen sich so mit diesen, ja
äh Querdenkern und äh anderen ähm
ja Freunden, die nicht ganz so sicher auf dem Boden der Verfassung stehen, auseinander und finden natürlich dort regelmäßig ähm,
sage mal, ähm großzügige Serverkonfiguration und da ist bei der bei der Basis ja äh relativ viel,
auch äh äh rausgekommen vor einigen Wochen. Ähm und ich denke, dass damit auch zum Beispiel es zu tun hat, dass man jetzt äh dass es jetzt Artikel zum Beispiel rüber gibt, dass Volker Bruch dort einen,
Mitgliedsbeitrag Mitgliedsantrag gestellt hat und so man, das ist wirklich, es ist so schade. Es ist so schade.
Kommen wir aber gleich nochmal zu, dass ich äh,
wahrscheinlich die die Leute weiteres Wasser auf ihren Mühlen bekommen werden. Machen wir erstmal noch weiter mit dem äh Naziblock hier, bevor wir zum Corona-Blog kommen. Ähm der NSU zwei Punkt null,
Absender soll jetzt der mutmaßliche äh Absender soll in Berlin festgenommen worden sein.
Dass wir erinnern uns, dass das ging, seit,
August zwanzig achtzehn muss das losgegangen sein, hätte ich jetzt auch ungefähr geschätzt, dass Menschen
Drohschreiben bekamen, sehr viele Leute, viele Prominente, ähm
Wir haben ja mit hier auch äh gesprochen, die solche Nachrichten bekommen hat. Und das war dann irgendwie,
ähm.
Ja immer irgendwelche Drohungen und äh quasi man die wurden unterschrieben als der NSU zwei Punkt null, natürlich bezogen auf hier Uwe Mundlos, wie hieß der andere Uwe?
Uwe, oder?
Ja ähm.
Beate Zschäpe, Uwe, Mundlos und Uwe, warum fällt mir da jetzt der Name nicht ein? Was ist mit B?
Uwe, Burnhard.
Ja, so die diese ähm Nazimörderbande,
die äh über viele Jahre hier in Deutschland Menschen getötet hat und ähm wo,
lange Zeit äh diese,
Mordopfer dann irgendwie von der deutschen Polizei verdächtigt wurden irgendwo, die müssen ja irgendwo in der organisierten Kriminalität da gewesen sein und äh irgendwann stellte sich raus, dass es eben eine,
gab, die hier über Jahre gemordet hat. Ein ganz, ganz äh dunkles Kapitel.
Und darauf bezog sich eben dieser Autor, in dem er seine Nachrichten mit NSU zwei Punkt null,
unterschrieb. Ähm die anscheinend hat der also einhundertdreiunddreißig solcher,
Drohschreiben versendet und einige wurden dann Trittbrettfahrern äh,
zugeordnet, also hundertfünf Cent scheint jetzt eher geschickt zu haben an zweiunddreißig Personen und sechzig Institutionen. So und das Problem an dieser Sache, wie gesagt, das,
ihr ihr erinnert euch wahrscheinlich an das Gespräch, dass Konstanz und ich mit geführt haben, war.
Dass diese Adressen an die dort gesandt, an die das gesandt wurde, offenbar aus Polizei ähm Registern,
ausgelesen wurden. Und es war immer irgendwie so ein Thema. Die Polizisten, die das dann gemacht haben, haben gesagt, ich war das nicht. Man hat sich immer Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie ist denn diese,
wie sind denn diese Täter oder dieser Täter, an die Adressen gekommen? Und anscheinend,
soll das jetzt so gewesen sein, dass der bei der Polizei angerufen hat.
Sich von denen hat die Adressdaten geben lassen, irgendwie so so getan hat, als wäre ein Kollege oder so. Machst du mal eben hier,
Feststellung von so und so und das hätte funktioniert. Es gibt jetzt an dieser Darstellung doch ähm,
einige Zweifel, also einige zweifeln daran, dass das jetzt nur eine Person war, andere zweifeln daran, dass es jetzt wirklich so funktioniert sein soll, dass er.
Einfach nur bei der Polizei angerufen hat, ähm kommt irgendwie ein bisschen äh kommt irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch alles.
Bisschen komisch ist gut. Also ich meine, entweder hat da jemand bei der Polizei angerufen und zwar vielleicht auch immer dieselbe Person, die dann einfach die Adressen rausgerückt hat. Da würde ich ja dann
glatt äh noch mit
gehen, dann ist aber natürlich die Frage, wer war diese Person? Aber die Vorstellung, dass jetzt irgend so ein arbeitsloser äh Hobbynazi regelmäßig bei der Polizei anruft und die ihm dann einfach die
Adressen irgendwelcher Prominenter,
Oder sonst irgendwie ähm bekannter Personen diktieren. Das äh würde mich ja noch sehr viel mehr beunruhigen, weil
das ist ja irgendwie alles völlig im Eimer.
Also ich bin auch äh nicht ganz überzeugt.
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, noch nicht das Ende der Geschichte.
Es ist aber bisher auch nur eine These oder also eine Hypothese und die sollte sich jetzt bestätigen. Also werden wir mal, da bleiben wir auf jeden Fall dran und äh ich bin mal sehr sehr gespannt, wie das äh weitergeht.
Die Story, er hätte typischen Behördensprech.
Typischen Behörden spricht. Mhm. Woher kannte er denn? War er schon mal in der Behörde?
Deswegen also ich lass uns mal also das ist der Stand jetzt, diese diese Verhaftung soll heute stattgefunden haben, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wenn ihr das hört.
Ist schon neue Erkenntnisse gibt. Deswegen äh würde ich sagen, vertagen wir das mal auf die nächste Sendung und äh kommen.
Wusste ich aber auch gerne, wie dieser Behördensprech funktioniert. Vielleicht können wir ja auch unsere Sendung noch ein bisschen effizienter in die Institutionen tragen, die Inhalte, wenn wir hier einfach auch mehr Behörden, sprich an den Tag legen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie wie Behörden sprechen.
Na ja, ich bin da auch nicht sonderlich geübt, würde ich sagen, aber ist halt äh sicherlich einfach so eine Szene typische Ansprache.
Ich denke, ich denke, ich denke wahrscheinlich irgendwie so zu auf jeden Fall schon mal total gelangweilt.
Ähm weiß ich nicht. Wie man halt so anruft, wenn man eben mehr von so einer Nebenstelle kommt.
So, weißt du, so ein bisschen kollegial, so Frau Klingelbiel, kannst du kannst du mir mal, kannst du mir mal die Adressen raussuchen.
Ja, ich bin das wieder. Kannst du mir mal eben die Einreise von Ihnen.
Ich habe die, ich brauche die, ich brauche dich immer für die Akte. Weißt du, so was.
Ich habe schon wieder.
Nee, das ist ja in Frankfurt. Also du, lass uns, lass uns wirklich da jetzt nicht weiter drüber spekulieren. Ist auch eigentlich also ist ja auch tatsächlich nicht witzig, weil das ein riesiges Problem ist tatsächlich. Vielleicht um das noch kurz abzu äh grenzen.
Diese Registerzugriffe, die sind für äh für die Polizeiarbeit ähm ja, zulässig. Die müssen das auch äh sehr, sehr regelmäßig machen.
Sehr viel häufiger als man meint und in den meisten Fällen,
eben auch äh ja berechtigt und ohne einen äh missbräuchlichen Hintergrund. Und ähm,
Ich weiß, dass es da durchaus äh Arbeitsgruppen und Überlegungen und Pläne gibt, wie man,
das hinkriegt, dass man eben quasi von vermutlich sehr vielen berechtigten Abfragen die wenigen unberechtigten Abfragen
ähm ja, detektieren und filtern kann. Und was ja also da geht's ja dann los damit, dass diese IT-Systeme halt nur noch personalisiert zugreifbar sind
Tatsächlich ist das ja im Moment eher so, dass es da halt einen Rechner gibt mit einem Passwort und das klebt halt mit einem Post-it dran und da kann jeder dran, ne, weil das eben einfach etwas ist, was die den laufenden
im laufenden, am laufenden Band bei der Arbeit machen müssen, aus welchem Grund auch immer, haben wir auch nicht ganz eingeleuchtet, aber machen sie wohl.
Ja, aber trotzdem kann man nicht ganz ausschließen, dass es hier auch so eine Social Engineering Komponente gegeben haben kann, dass einfach jemand quasi so von der Seite kommt und diese ganzen Terminal-Bediener von der Seite bedient hat. Ja,
eben Stichwort Behördensprech äh einfach weiß, wie solche, ach kannst du mir mal schnell,
weißt du, mal raussuchen und ich ich brauche grad mal und ich sitze gerade nicht am Rechner und so, weißt du? Das funktioniert ja auch ein Stück weit.
So wie ich mir das erkläre habe erklären lassen, ist das tatsächlich zum Beispiel so, dass die halt über Funk.
Ähm oder äh über Telefon halt mal anrufen, weil sie diese Abfragen eben auf der Streife nicht machen können.
Also das ist nicht, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht ausgeschlossen, aber es muss eben ausgeschlossen sein.
Lass uns mal jetzt nicht weiter spekulieren. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass äh.
Noch mehr Details rauskommen. Das wird noch Juicy. Auf jeden Fall.
Weißt du, irgend so ein Feigling, der ähm der hundertfünfzehn Drohmails verschickt, wenn der mal hier äh die ähm in unserer äh Merkel-Diktatur erstmal in den in den äh im Kerker liegt, dann winselt der doch sofort.
Der singt doch jedes Lied. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher. Ja, wenn der hier erstmal die Merkel.
Ja, schauen wir mal. So, Schluss hier mit äh Nazis.
Naziblock vorbei. Ähm kommen wir zum Corona-Blog. Es geht los mit ein bisschen Statistiken zur Corona-Warnefft. Da gab's ein Handelsblattartikel
Ähm und da sind,
wollte ich einfach mal nur so ein bisschen Nutzungsstatistiken wiedergeben, die weil wir da ja uns auch immer drüber geärgert haben, dass man so wenig ähm findet.
Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit, Daten freizugeben für die Weiterentwicklung der App.
Das machen inzwischen wohl sechs Komma fünf der siebenundzwanzig Millionen Nutzerinnen. Ähm.
Und wenn jetzt quasi eine,
Also wenn man im Durchschnitt schaut, wenn ein eine Nutzerin mit dem Virus infiziert ist und das meldet, erhalten im Schnitt sechs andere eine Hochrisikowarnung. Und das ist äh das fand ich einen sehr spannenden Wert, weil das zeigt,
jetzt ist natürlich, also ich habe das ja hier schon oft gesagt, das Infektionsgeschehen ist nicht äh,
deterministisch, sondern stochastisch und das heißt, es gibt einfach nicht eine einzige Situation, die man definieren kann, in der die Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit eins ist. Und deswegen ist so eine Warnung immer mit einem.
Risiko behaftet äh falsch zu sein und äh mit einem Risiko behaftet äh und eine Nichtwarnung mit dem Risiko behaftet äh ebenfalls äh nicht nicht fälschlich nicht gewarnt zu haben. Ähm.
Wenn so im Schnitt sechs eine Warnung erhalten und das DR-Wert ist immer, wie ist der so Tim? Bei.
Irgendwo um eins rum, ne? Das heißt, das im Zweifelsfall, viele, die auch schon viele dieser Warnungen eben ähm ja.
Ähm ja nicht richtig sind, ne, also die werden nicht alle jetzt auf eine Infektion deuten, aber es hält sich irgendwie halbwegs die Waage, ne.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, du sagst, wer wieder R-Wert ist.
Der aktuelle AirWert meinst du jetzt, wie wir.
Der höchste, den wir je hatten, ist, glaube ich, eins zwei und der niedrigste null sieben, oder?
Ja null sieben ist Mindestwert die höchsten, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht aus dem Kopf, kann ja aber kurz nachschlagen, ist auch immer die Frage welcher Wert herangezogen wird.
Habe ich aber jetzt gerade nicht im historischen Rückblick.
Und ähm weil der derzeit täglich etwa viertausend Nutzerinnen,
eine Corona-Infektion über die CWA melden, sind das ungefähr fünfundzwanzigtausend Hochrisiko und achtzigtausend hier äh Grüne Warnungen am Tag. Das ist schon ziemlich viel, ne? Ähm,
schon insgesamt zweieinhalb Millionen Warnungen äh durch diese App. Ähm ausgegangen,
Hätte ich jetzt nicht so geschätzt, vor allem weil ja alle immer so sagen, ja die äh die App funktioniert nicht, ich kriege keine Warnungen mehr und so, ne. Das äh fand ich schon,
spannend.
Das ist wirklich eine Menge, vor allem, wenn man mal bedenkt, so eine Warnung kann ja dann tatsächlich wirklich dazu führen, dass weitere Infektionen verhindert werden. So.
So und jetzt kommt nämlich der spannende, jetzt kommt nicht also
kann und das äh darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, was du gerade sagst, ist ja der einzige Grund, warum man das macht. Man schickt die Warnung, damit die Leute, die gewarnt sind, ihre Kontakte reduzieren, sich testen lassen, ja? Und jetzt haben sie ähm.
Das finde ich hier sehr spannend. Bei unter fünfzehntausend Nutzerinnen, die eine Hochrisikowarnung erhalten haben, haben sie mal eine Umfrage durchgeführt.
Und von denen gaben zwei Drittel an, dass sie über die Warnung überrascht gewesen waren.
Und die hätten ohne die war App womöglich nie vom Kontakt mit einer infizierten Person erfahren. Das ist auch sehr krass, ne? Also das heißt,
zwei Drittel der Warnungen hätten sie nicht bekommen, weil wir ja hier auch oft gesagt haben, ja,
häufig geht die Warnung vielleicht über WhatsApp äh raus oder so. Und wenn hier zwei Drittel der Leute die Warnung nicht haben, kommen sehen, dann deutet das darauf hin, dass das zum Beispiel eben die Situation abdeckt im,
Personennahverkehr irgendwo ähm.
Wo äh wo wo man eben auch diese Warnungen äh hinsenden möchte. Ja und dann über achtzig Prozent der gewarnten Nutzer ließen sich im Anschluss testen.
Sehr gut, ne? Also haben das getan, haben,
die Warnung ernst genommen, haben einen Test gemacht und dann bei sieben Prozent fiel der Test positiv aus.
Die achtzig Prozent haben sie jetzt aus diesen fünfzehntausend, die sie befragt haben, ermittelt.
Also von den fünfzehntausend haben achtzig Prozent sich testen lassen. Jetzt ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wir ziehen sich die sieben Prozent auf die achtzig Prozent Teilmenge oder auf die äh fünfzehntausend Menge, das weiß ich nicht, aber sieben Prozent fiel der Test dann.
Positiv aus, da im Schnitt sechs Warnungen verschickt werden, würde man eigentlich beinahe, würde man eigentlich eine höhere positiv,
erwarten.
Ich versuche das jetzt grad mal so ein bisschen hochzurechnen, wie viele Leute sozusagen dann durch die App gewarnt sind und sich dann positiv testen lassen. Ähm,
und sich damit sozusagen aus dem Verkehr ziehen, ne, also wenn,
haben wir jetzt ein bisschen zu wenig Zahlenmaterial, aber es wäre nochmal ganz interessant, das mal hochzurechnen, wie viele äh Infektionen quasi dadurch,
indirekt verhindert werden. Das kann natürlich nur so eine theoretische Zahl sein, aber ist ja nicht ganz ohne Grundlage. Und wenn man dann mal berücksichtigt, dass,
verhinderte Infektion im Prinzip den Staat tausend Euro spart im Schnitt kommt da ganz schön viel äh Geld zusammen.
Also das kannst du jetzt vereinfacht ausrechnen. Nehmen wir mal an, dass die sieben Prozent von den dass das sieben, diese sieben Prozent sich nur auf die achtzig Prozent beziehen, dann hast du achtzig Prozent von äh fünfzehntausend, Moment. Ähm.
Das sind ja jetzt nur die, die befragt wurden, ne? Man würde ja dann davon ausgehen, dass sich das dann auf alles bezieht, was so Warnungen bekommt.
Ne, du kannst ja, also du kannst das natürlich extra polieren und du müsstest jetzt äh da ist das Beste ist, was du hast, kannst du jetzt halt extra polieren, auf die fünfundzwanzigtausend Hochrisikowarnungen, die am Tag rausgehen,
Also es war noch nicht diese fünfzehntausend waren noch nicht mal das Warnungskontingent eines Tages.
Ja, ich meine, das wären da so tausendzweihundertfünfzig Leute pro Tag, die gewarnt werden und sich positiv getestet werden.
Das ist schon, das ist schon amtlich.
Mal tausend Euro gespart, die eine weitere Infektion verhindert haben. So hast du schon irgendwie zwölfeinhalb Millionen Euro pro Tag gespart.
Ja, also das war also ich fand diesen Bericht wirklich mal sehr äh spannend, weil, ne, kriege jeden Tag irgendwelche Mathegenies, die mit Prozenten dann da hantieren und sagen, die Corona-Warn-App hat uns alle in den Tod gestürzt und das funktioniert nicht oder so, ne?
Da sind natürlich so, da da bin ich ja auch ein bisschen verärgert, dass sowas halt in so einem Handelsblattartikel irgendwie unter
hinter der Paywall ist, die ich wo ich erstmal jemanden rauskratzen lassen muss, ne?
Sonst hätten wir das schon früher gesprochen. Also sehr, sehr äh überraschend gute Ergebnisse
trotz ja doch auch sehr starken Einschränkungen der App, ne? Auch das muss man ja sagen, wenn es nutzen hier eben offenbar nur siebenundzwanzig,
Millionen Menschen. Das sind bei weitem nicht alle und das bedeutet alle, die nicht mitmachen können.
Nicht dazu beitragen, dass die, dass Warnungen versendet werden und können auch keine Warnungen bekommen. Insofern würde die Effektivität dieser Warnung eben steigen, je mehr Leute,
diese App nutzen. Ähm wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass es ähm eine.
Angelegte Funktion in der Corona-Warn-App jetzt.
Ja, das haben wir ja hier, glaube ich, äh zu Genüge behandelt. Und da gab es dann jetzt ein, finde ich, bemerkenswertes Interview mit Ulrich Kälber im Spiegel.
Der eben sagt, okay, man muss der Corona-Warn-App jetzt die Fesseln abstreifen, wo sie auch diese Cluster und Check-in-Funktion hat ähm und die Fessel ist,
dass sie derzeit nicht offiziell zur Kontakterfassung an Orten wie Restaurants eingesetzt werden kann. Und das ist ja genau der Punkt in den Infektionsschutzverordnungen oder Corona-Infektionsschutzverordnungen
der Länder. So, jetzt hat das äh der Freistaat Sachsen tatsächlich ähm eine, ja, etwas sehr missverständlich formulierte
nicht eindeutig formuliert, der muss sogar als Jurist als Nichtjurist sagen, ja das ist irgendwie schwer äh leicht missverständlich, dass aber sie wird jetzt offenbar so interpretiert, dass die sagen.
Man kann in ein Restaurant gehen und damit der Corona-Warn-App einchecken. Und wenn man das nicht möchte,
muss man eben seine Adresse dalassen. So, das ist jetzt mal, wurde von Ulrich Kälber auch mit so einem als äh als das ewig getwittert wurde, hat,
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Ulrich Kälber, so ein so ein Gift da drunter gehauen. Das fand ich auch schon,
cool. Also ich bin ja inzwischen wieder ganz happy mit dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten in äh der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Wir hatten da ja mal zwischenzeitlich ähm.
Ein kleines Tief.
So ein Forsthof tief, ne, aber das äh,
ähm Kälber ist da wirklich an der an der Sache dran, hat dem auch einen ganz ist äh so ein tech affiner Typ auch, der sich in die Dinge da reinfuchst und so ähm.
Ja, der auch, sagen wir mal, eine Position hat. Also der, der da nicht einfach nur so rumlaviert und irgendwie so das das Minimum tut, sondern der sich einfach engagiert und und ja, diskutiert auch und offen ist auch für Diskussionen.
Eine ähnliche Position vertritt auch die äh Datenschutzkonferenz, ähm die sich da auch nochmal mit dem Thema des contact-Tracing auseinandergesetzt hat. Ja und Sachsen,
wer hätte gedacht, dass ausgerechnet Sachsen jetzt vorgeht. Sachsen ist aber, glaube ich, was Content angeht sowieso. Ähm,
vermutlich irgendwie ganz zähen, der ich kann die Coronapolitik Sachsens äh höre ich eigentlich sonst nicht so viel Gutes drüber, aber ähm zumindest bei dem contact-Tracing haben sie sich auch kein,
Luca andrehen lassen. Insofern, da scheinen irgendwie zumindest in dem Bereich äh fähige Leute zu setzen.
Dann gab es ähm gestern eine.
Fachgespräch im Bundestagsausschuss Digitale Agenda zum contact training. Jetzt muss ich ja gucken, ob ich alle Sachverständigen da noch auf die Reihe kriege. Also da war der Arne Schönboom. Das ist der.
Chef vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, hat noch mal ein sehr äh positives ähm
Fazit über die Corona-Warn-App gezogen. In dem habe ich, äh ich war auch einer der Sachverständigen, dort komme ich gleich zu äh Anne Schönbuben
sagte, er hält es, sie ist eine der sichersten Apps im App Store. Und der hat ja vermutlich recht mit, weil,
weil die halt einfach aufgrund ihrer Architektur kann da auch einfach gar nicht viel schiefgehen. Das hatte ich dann, ne, wegen der dezentralen Anonymen und sonstwas, ne, also allein die Restrisiken dieser Apps sind einfach so gering,
alles eine ganze Menge anderer Sachen vorher um die Nase fliegt. Also BSI sehr positives Urteil.
Bei Design einfach.
Genau, ne? Also Risiken von vorne herein gar nicht erst aufbauen, dann brauchst du sie auch nicht zu mitigieren und äh ja, war ganz, also war,
war guter Dinge der und ebenso natürlich der Ulrich Kälber, der war ebenfalls dort als Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter.
Dann war der Martin Fassunge von SAP da. Das ist einer der leitenden Entwickler äh an der Corona,
Warn-App. Ähm hat also so ein bisschen Auskunft gegeben über diese neue Funktionalität. Das fand ich sehr spannend. Der wurde dann gefragt, äh wie lange sie denn gebraucht haben.
Um diese QR-Code-Check-Infunktion zu bauen. Ähm.
Und seine Antwort war drei Wochen. Das verhalte ich für realistisch, weil.
Ne. Hat er auch gesagt, fand ich, also muss man sagen. Dann hat er gesagt, ja klar, weil das war ja schon fertig gespeckt,
Das gab's ja seit Oktober ähm im Internet.
Konnte man sich ja die Spex durchlesen. Die haben ja hier ähm Michael Veal und so alle halt schon geliefert
und das hat ja dann auch wirklich nochmal erwähnt, hat er gesagt, so da mussten wir ja, das mussten wir ja nur noch runterschreiben, so ungefähr und äh ja, warum ist diese Frage so spannend? Ja, weil sich damit eben auch ergibt, dass sie's, wenn sie den Auftrag
November bekommen hätten.
Eben auch im Dezember fertig gehabt hätten zum Einsatz im Januar. Danach gefragt, hat er irgendwie gesagt, ja im Februar hätten sie es fertig haben können, ne. Ähm.
Weil da natürlich noch ein paar andere Sachen eine Rolle spielen, weil sie ja auch andere Dinge machen müssen,
Erweiterung an der App, aber er hat relativ klar gesagt, diese Funktionalität hätte also ein paar Monate vorher da sein können, wenn sie,
vorher beauftragt worden wäre, was ja auch meine Hauptkritik am,
Ministerium für Gesundheit ist, nicht meine Hauptkritik an Jens Spahn, aber in dieser Angelegenheit meine Hauptkritik an ihren Spahn.
Ja, überhaupt gab es ja so eine Phase, also ich weiß nicht, ob er sich dazu auch geäußert hat, aber das war so schwer mein Eindruck. Äh nach
dem so die Kernfunktionalität am Start war, ist erstmal ja nicht so viel passiert äh Feature mäßig, ne? Klar, es wurde noch weiter dran gearbeitet, aber es war nicht mehr so der Fokus. Und jetzt in der letzten Zeit hat man ja gemerkt, dass sie wirklich Schlag auf Schlag wieder neue Features rausgehauen haben,
Man hätte einfach diese Schlagzahl von vornherein eben hochhalten äh,
müssen und dann hätte man auch sehr viel früher geahnt, wie wertvoll dieses Tool noch für viele andere Sachen sein äh kann, die ja jetzt teilweise kommen. Wir kommen ja noch dazu, Impfpass und so weiter,
andere Funktionalitäten sind vorstellbar, dass so ein bisschen die verpasste Chance gewesen, man wusste gar nicht, was man da für ein,
Edelstein sich mittlerweile herangezüchtet hat.
Henning Tillmann war da, D vierundsechzig. Ähm hat er allgemeine Statements abgegeben.
Sagt der, Deutschland ist spät dran mit den Weiterentwicklungen der Corona-Warn-App. Damit hat er natürlich Recht. Ähm,
er hat ein bisschen auch auf Probleme dieser QR-Code Geschichten angesprochen. Grundsätzlich, also nicht nur bei der Corona-Warn-App. Jetzt zum Beispiel ausloggen beim Verlassen einer Location.
Ähm und äh die Corona-Warn macht das ja äh einfach so, dass man so eine,
Typische Verweildauer angibt und dann macht läuft der Timer aus. Bei Luca wird das ja äh über GPS gemacht. Da ist man quasi über so ein GPS-Fans. Ähm
Also da hat er auch so ein paar Problemchen hingewiesen, die äh die in beiden Systemen noch so existieren und hat auch, ne, das ist ja,
auch eine Forderung von dir Tim gesagt so insgesamt muss die App einfach mal interessanter sein, zum Beispiel mehr Informationen zum,
Pandemiegeschehen anzeigen. Auch das äh ja eine sinnvolle Forderung.
Und die Lotterie, nicht zu vergessen.
Lotterie hat, glaube ich, keiner mehr gefordert, aber ja, du hast recht. Äh da wäre wenigstens mal ein bisschen Schwung in die Bude gekommen.
Ja, also rechtlich bestimmt schwierig, aber einfach, ja. Vielleicht hätte ich ja auch gewonnen.
Dann war dort Bianca Kastel, Bianca Kastel, der Name ist hier vor Kurzem schon gefallen, die war ähm an der ähm Entdeckung von Luca Track beteiligt, ne? Und also dem Schlüssel Anhänger,
bei dem man die Kontakthistorie Zugang zu Kontakthistorie mit im QR-Code hat.
War aber jetzt dort in ihrer Funktion als äh für das Gesundheitsamt Bodensee Kreis tätige,
Betreuerin im Bereich der IT und hat ein bisschen was darüber gesagt, ja was,
was wollen wir überhaupt für Daten haben? Ne, also welche, was hilft einem Gesundheitsamt und was hilft einem Gesundheitsamt nicht? Ähm dass man sich nämlich eigentlich nicht im Tagesgeschäft mit den Gästelisten auseinandersetzt. Auch das hatte ich ja hier schon,
versucht zu argumentieren, ähm dass das in der Regel nicht gemacht wird, weil das eben der größere Teil dieser Kontakte eben nicht,
Relevant ist für das Infektionsgeschehen, ja? Da hat sie also noch dann auch bei der Luca App noch ein bisschen was zu Barrierefreiheit äh gesagt. Die Datenqualität ähm,
ist nicht unbedingt an der Menge zu bemessen und so weiter.
Wenn man jetzt mal guckt so für solche Leute hätte man dann so einen Henning Tillmann und ein Linus Neumann auch einfach mal ausladen können,
um sich mehr auch mal einfach dieser Bedarfsträger anzuhören, die dann eben mal sagen so, so sieht das übrigens bei uns aus. Und da,
da staut sich ja jetzt schon so in den, in den Berichten zu diesem Thema und in Interviews zu dem Thema jetzt schon langsam, der bei den Gesundheitsämtern entstandener Eindruck, dass die nämlich sagen so, wir waren irgendwie die letzten, die hier gefragt wurden.
Uns hat keiner gefragt, ob wir eine, ob wir eine PP App haben wollen oder sowas, ne. Jetzt haben wir den Kram da und ja gut, die haben uns, wir haben schon noch ganz andere. Wir haben schon ganz andere Sachen äh hier ausgesessen, aber wer vielleicht ganz gut gewesen.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein generelles Problem, ne. Da werden einfach Lösungen vorgeschlagen, ohne dass man ausreichend Konsultationen äh herstellt mit,
den Entitäten, die letzten Endes, die dann umsetzen sollen. Ja, Anbindung an diese Gesundheitsämter und die Gesundheitsämter so, was? Habt ihr eine Meise? Geht mir weg.
So, dann war der Martin Schiersich da, das sollte wirklich der die äh Runde der bekannten Namen, also Martin Schiersig, ähm ja bekannt durch seine,
Vorträge zu Gesundheitsdaten auf dem Kongress sicherlich auch ähm bekannt durch den.
Vortrag über den äh Heck der Bundestagswahl zusammen mit Thorsten und mir und er war jetzt dort allerdings als Vertreter,
des Innovationsverbunds öffentliche Gesundheit. Ähm.
Er ist übrigens auch bekannt äh für seine Auftritte in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik zwohundertachtundzwanzig und dreihundertsechsunddreißig.
Eier.
Kannst du auch noch direkt verlinken. So und der war dort als als ähm äh Vertreter des Innovationsverbunds öffentliche Gesundheit. Ich sage, also in dem Fall tatsächlich Vertreter des eigentlich geladenen, also die haben quasi gesagt
also die hatten eigentlich jemand anderen geladen. Er hatte wegen der Zeit. Das ähm.
Äh aus irgendwelchen Terminkollisionen eben diese Stellungnahme dann eben übernommen, hat das auch klar gesagt, dass er da jetzt quasi jemand anderes vertritt und die haben eine offene Schnittstelle namens Iris. Ähm
die ermöglichen soll, dass mehrere Akteure an der Kontaktverfolgung mitwirken können ähm und das wäre also kein,
wäre also ein offener Standard für die,
letzte Meile ins äh Gesundheitsamt, bei der man darauf achten will, dass die Daten bedarfsgetrieben sind und nicht,
einfach nur da reingeballert werden. Ja, äh das sind dann im Zweifelsfall, ne, die die die vernünftigen Positionen, die einfach überrollt wurden so, ne, muss man halt auch äh leider sagen.
Und ähm dann war dort noch äh der CEO der Luca-App äh des Berliner State,
Startups der Xenia Patrick Hennig ähm,
sage jetzt einfach mal, ich lese jetzt einfach aus von Bundestag DE ab, was er gesagt hat. Der CEO der Luca-App des Berliner Startups betonte, dass sich die Firma bewusst sei,
Datensicherheit und Datenschutz erfüllt sein müssen. Auch deshalb sei der Quellkurd ihres System offen gelegt um eine Weiterentwicklung der Software zu ermöglichen.
Können sie ja machen. Der die Einsatzbereiche im Vergleich zu CWA seien unterschiedlich. Die Luca-App könne Gesundheitsämtern, gute Hinweise geben, um zum Beispiel ein Hygienekonzept eines Ortes zu überprüfen.
Auch erste Daten aus Modellregionen wie Nordfriesland zeigten, dass die App funktionieren. Ähm,
Also, viel Spaß, liebe Orte, ja, wenn wenn demnächst das Gesundheitsamt vorbeikommt und sagt, hör mal, wir haben ja schon den zweiten Luca-Vorfall bei euch. Wir wollen mal gucken, wie,
wie das hier bei euch mit den Gläser spülen ist.
Das dürfte die Locations jetzt auch nicht unbedingt weiter begeistern äh diese App zu nutzen. Aber klar, er hat äh äh auf die Probleme angesprochen natürlich immer eine äh Lösung,
versprochen, was soll er auch anderes machen, würde ich den Mann jetzt auch überhaupt nicht vorwerfen, dass wenn man sagt, hier gab's ein Problem in deiner App, dass er dann sagt, das lösen wir jetzt. Ähm.
Ich war auch da. Ich würde mich jetzt auch kurz äh einfach mal hier vom Bundestag DE ablesen. Ich ich mache auch einen Link in die zu dem Video von der Anhörung. Ähm,
Kritik an der Luca-App äußerte auch Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computerclub,
es betrübe ihn, dass über einundzwanzig Komma acht Millionen Euro für ein Jahreslizenz in einer zentralen Lösung ausgegeben wurden, bei der es immer wieder Sicherheitslücken wie etwa bei den Fake-Check-Ins und den sogenannten Schlüsselanhängern gebe.
Entscheidend seien die Zielgerichtetheit und Effizienz, um auch die Gesundheitsämter zu entlasten,
nicht zu belasten. Die Clusterfunktion der CWA sei überfällig, der Chaos-Computerclub habe diese bereits seit Oktober zwanzig zwanzig,
gefordert. Ja, fühle ich mich halbwegs äh gut mit wiedergegeben und ähm ja, gibt ähm gibt ein Video von der von der Anhörung. Es war.
Also es sind im Moment sehr viele Anhörungen.
Und deswegen war quasi der Streaming-Dienst da äh da war, die waren irgendwie nicht voll besetzt. Und deswegen ist die, dieser Ausschuss Anhörung jetzt ernsthaft so ein Web-Ex-Mitschnitt.
Habe ich überhaupt noch nicht erlebt. Und zwar im im in der Kachel View,
Und da sind ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Leute im im Webxt drin, ne. Also das das ist der äh wirklich relativ äh peinlich,
von der Qualität her, vor allem weil wenn jetzt eine Person spricht, dann bleibt das trotzdem in dieser und und man sieht dann halt einfach nur so so einen kleinen, einer von den Mosaiksteinchen bewegt sich mehr als die anderen.
Ist wirklich das, was ich äh sehr bald überhaupt nicht mehr sehen möchte.
Keinen zumuten, kannst du.
Es geht auf Dauer einfach.
Nein, das geht nicht. Das kann man nicht machen. Und äh das, das war auf jeden Fall ganz amüsant und und eine andere Sache war auch amüsant und da fragst du dich echt.
Warum? Habe ich das heute nicht verstanden. Und zwar haben die sich da in diesem Ausschuss vorher offenbar kurzfristig.
Darüber auseinandergesetzt, ob denn nun das Gesundheitsministerium angehört wird oder nicht.
Wäre ja durchaus mal vielleicht spannend, wenn man sich über Clustererkennungsapp auseinandersetzt, äh mit mit Clustererkennungsapps auseinandersetzt und,
dann muss SAP, da die die CWA erklären, die aber eigentlich ja das BMG in Auftrag gegeben hat, aber es hat sich offenbar eine,
politische Partei dagegen gewehrt, dass das BMG eingeladen wird in diesen Ausschuss Digitale Agenda. Und das war offenbar die CDU oder die große Koalition
Die haben gesagt, nee, wir wollen nicht, dass das Gesundheitsministerium angehört wird. In unserem Ausschuss zum Thema.
Zu dem Thema gerade in der aktuellen Krise.
Und das hatte dann
dass am Anfang der Sitzung, weil der Vertreter von BMG war eingewählt, der war ja nun mal geladen, der hatte sein Web Extra ja an. Und dann hat am Anfang von der Sitzung der Manuel Höferline gesagt, ja und dann haben wir hier noch den Herrn vom Gesundheitsamt
Schröder oder so hieß der, wie auch immer, herzlich willkommen. Wir haben sie jetzt, wir laden sie jetzt wieder aus. Sie können gerne sitzen bleiben und zuhören. Ist ja eine öffentliche Anhörung. Aber an sie stellen wir heute keine Fragen.
Also nicht gesundheitsamt, sondern vom.
Schöne Gesundheits.
Ja okay, ich habe das dann trotzdem an, ist ja vielleicht interessant. Ja okay, tschüss.
Also die FDP waren das doch, die haben auch die ganze Zeit Witze dadrüber gemacht und haben gesagt, so das wäre echt mal eine Frage, die man dem,
Gesundheitsministerium stellen könnte, wenn wir die jetzt wenn die Koalition, die nicht ausgeladen hätte und es ist wirklich auch völlig unklar, warum die das getan haben,
Also verstehe ich wirklich nicht.
Verstehe ich auch nicht.
Na ja, das war das.
Währenddessen geht das lustige Rumäkeln auf Luca echt weiter ja es gab jetzt das hab ich auch in dem Ausschuss nochmal erwähnt das Kollektiv.
Die sind jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt, irgendwie die ganze Zeit mit krassen technischen Hacks aufzutreten,
von denen gab es, gibt es jetzt die die Lucy App? Schöne, schöne Namensgebung, ist 'ne Webseite,
gehst du drauf, kannst du.
Mit einem QR-Code-Scanner, also es funktioniert ja wie die Luca-App und dann kannst du einen QR-Code scannen und dann kannst du dort eingeben, wen du einchecken möchtest. Dann hast du mehrere Sachen zur Auswahl. Ähm zum Beispiel fünfundzwanzig Max Mustermänner,
alle Ministerpräsidentin, vier Popmusiker oder nur dich anonym. Und ähm.
Was das Ding also demonstriert ist, ne, dass man in dieser Luca-App einfach hinschicken kann, was man möchte. Es liegt eben daran, dass die,
Daten, die er dort eingecheckt werden, verschlüsselt sind. Das heißt, beim Check-In kann die keiner auf Echtheit prüfen.
Und ähm wenn du jetzt in einer äh Loop in eine Luka Location gehst,
wo Check-In Zwang herrscht, ja? Ähm,
dann steht da jemand potentiell, also idealerweise steht da jemand und guckt an dem Backend, wo dieser Zähler hochzählt. Ähm und da sehen die dann einfach, ne, check mal ein und dann zählt geht in dem Backend einfach der Zähler hoch, eine Person, eine weitere Person eingecheckt.
Und ähm,
das ist quasi der Weg, wie die kontrollieren, dass du den Code auch wirklich gescannt hast oder kontrollieren sollen. Wenn du da jetzt halt Fake-Daten hinschickst, dann kommst du halt rein ohne deine Daten
hinterlegt zu haben, dass er erstmal ein Problem. Zweitens, was das Ding demonstriert, wenn du hier halt fünfundzwanzig Leute eincheckst, ne? Oder du machst das mit einem QR-Code, den du irgendwo im Internet gefunden hast, dann kannst du halt irgendwo auf der Welt,
In diesem Fall fünfundzwanzig Leute einchecken. Das ist ja jetzt nur eine Demo, die er quasi limitiert ist, ne? Du kannst natürlich auch hundert einchecken oder hunderttausend. Das ist ja auch genau das, wovor wir ähm.
In dem CCC Statement schon gewarnt haben, ähm dass genau das möglich ist. Ähm.
Was sie dazu noch gemacht haben, ist echt so ein ganz lustiges Video,
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir das vielleicht am ans Ende dranschneiden, wenn Tim nicht noch ein viel geileres äh Auto hat für die Sendung. Ansonsten ist er auf jeden Fall verlinkt. Kann man sich mal angucken, ist wirklich sehr,
sehr cool gemacht, genauso wie auch eben hier diese Lucy App. Und jetzt kommt, das war sehr spannende Diskussion, weil,
Ich glaube, als jetzt gezeigt wurde, dass, ne, nicht nur irgendwelche Nerds wie wir, sagen, das geht,
oder irgendwelche anderen Nerds äh hier, ne und hier in der Browserkonsole und so weiter und ich habe im im Gitlab geguckt und das geht und guck mal hier, ne, sondern wirklich einfach mal hier,
eine Kommunikationsgerätegruppe sagt, hier, zack, bumm läuft, ne.
Kriegen sogar wir hin und noch ein lustiges Video dazu machen, dann wird den Leuten halt langsam klar, du, das ist wirklich ein Problem, ne? Und warum ist das ein Problem? Erstens, weil du den Check-In umgehen kannst und zweitens, weil der ganze Datenmüll dann bei den Gesundheitsämtern landet,
Jetzt hat sich Luca dafür eine Lösung überlegt.
Ähm die dann auch ähm in Reaktion auf diese Peng-Aktion mitgeteilt wurde und diese Lösung sieht so aus.
Die werden also jetzt die SMS-Tannen verifizierung von den Telefonnummern scharf schalten.
So damit riskiert, würden sie ja eigentlich, wenn sie das,
naiv machen, würden sie damit eben die Privatsphäre der Nutzerinnen opfern, weil dann ist eine hast du eben nicht mehr einen anonymen Account, sondern ein fest auf deine Telefonnummer.
Ähm registrierten Account. Um das zu umgehen, machen sie jetzt folgendes.
Gucken, ob du wirklich die die Telefonnummer verifiziert hast,
Also die Gurkenserverseitig A, du hast uns den Code gesendet, den wir dir über SMS geschickt haben. Und was du dann als Antwort bekommst, ist deine Telefonnummer,
aber signiert von denen. Also designieren dir deine Telefonnummer,
und sagen, das ist eine verifizierte Telefonnummer. Und jetzt kommt der Trick, gar nicht so blöd, dann vergessen die deine Nummer aber wieder.
Und du schreibst jetzt quasi in diesen verschlüsselten Blog, deine signierte Telefonnummer rein.
Ja, also du checkst ein, ja, mit deiner Luca-App und dann schreibst du in dieses, in diese Datenfelder kommt deine signierte Telefonnummer
Und wenn die jetzt dann nachher irgendwann mal die Daten abgreifen, dann werden die von der Betreiberin entschlüsselt, vom Gesundheitsamt entschlüsselt und dann können die sehen oder können die prüfen,
sind die Telefonnummern, die sich hier befinden,
signiert von uns und sagen dann, wenn da unsignierte Telefonnummern dabei sind, dann schmeißen wir die einfach raus. Um,
hier, das Gesundheitsamt nicht mit Fakedaten zu belasten.
Nicht mit Fake, Telefonnummern.
Genau
Na ja und sie würden ja zumindest nicht mit fake genau. Und weil die Telefonnummer vermutlich das Wichtigste in diesem Kontext ist, ne, so sagen sie
genau, wir wir belasten euch nicht mit äh fake Telefonnummern und im Zweifelsfall werden Leute, die ihre richtige Telefonnummer registriert haben, auch die richtigen anderen Daten richtig haben. Und wenn nicht, ist auch egal, weil wir rufen sie eh an
Ne, dann gibt's wenigstens echte Telefonnummern. So, gar nicht so unelegante Lösungen für allerdings nur die Hälfte des Problems,
denn was ja jetzt wieder passiert, was trotzdem noch geht,
ist der Fake-Check-In, der sich nämlich mit irgendwelchen Mülldaten da reinkomme und äh es am Einlass so aussieht, als wäre alles äh richtig und in Ordnung und äh prima,
Das heißt, diese Lucy App wird weiter funktionieren.
Es wird nur nicht so sein, dass ähm das Gesundheitsamt diese Daten sich potenziell am Ende auch angucken muss und du damit das Gesundheitsamt nicht spamst. Das heißt, eigentlich sage ich mal das schlechte Gefühl,
bei der Nutzung der Lucy App geht dann weg. Weil du nicht mehr das Gesundheitsamt spamt. Das andere Problem ist aber,
die haben ja laut eigenen Angaben jetzt schon ein paar Millionen Nutzerinnen im Feld. Und da frage ich mich ja,
was wollte er denn jetzt mit denen machen? Wollt ihr den jetzt irgendwie Nachricht schicken und sagen, übrigens wir müssen nochmal deine Telefonnummer verifizieren,
wir hätten wir würden das gerne nochmal neu machen mit dir bei unserer anonymen App hier, die die Datenschutz und so weiter hat, das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass sie das machen.
Ach, ist schon, also.
Nähe, also und ich kann dir sagen, warum ich das warum ich das nicht glaube. Jeder weiß, also wenn du wenn du sowas machst, so alles, was irgendwie eine Nutzer.
Interaktion verlangt und sonst funktioniert das nicht mehr oder so, ne? Führt gerne mal dazu, dass die Leute dann sagen, okay, dann eben nicht.
WhatsApp ist gerade hier,
am Rumrotieren, um den Leuten zu sagen, stimmt mal jetzt den neuen Benutzungsbedingungen, Zusatz funktioniert WhatsApp wieder nicht mehr, ne? Und für sowas nehmen die sich drei Monate Zeit,
ja? Ähm die Leute irgendwie dazu zu bringen, äh einen neuen Vertrag zu unterschreiben. Und das äh das macht man sehr ungerne. Insofern bin ich mal gespannt, ob Luca das wirklich macht,
Ich vermute, sie werden's nicht ohne Not machen. Das wäre jetzt so mein Gefühl. Also,
Zweifelsfall will ich einfach alle Neuen signieren, weil ich meine, diese Nachricht, diese Aussage, wenn die Telefonnummer nicht signiert ist, filtern wir euch wieder raus. Die klingt zwar erstmal schön, aber nicht, wenn
alle deine Nutzer bisher keine signierten Telefonnummern haben, ne? Und die dürfen ja sich bei dieser Sache nicht einen einzigen Fehler leisten,
und dann am Ende irgendjemanden nicht waren, der der tatsächlich,
oder die tatsächlich sich legitim da eingecheckt hat. Also ich bin von der Lösung noch nicht so ganz überzeugt. Erstens bin ich nicht überzeugt, dass die,
äh ähm dass das also erstens löst sie nur die Hälfte des Problems, weil man kommt trotzdem einfach noch rein,
und das ist dir ja dann egal, ob das Gesundheitsamt die Fake-Daten hat oder nicht, ist ja eigentlich sogar besser, wenn du reinkommst, ohne dass das Gesundheitsamt mit deinen Daten, mit Fakedaten belästigt wird und ähm.
Zweitens glaube ich halt nicht, dass sie das Feature so unbedingt ins Feld ausgerollt kriegen.
Ja, das war so ein bisschen, dass die die die Woche in Luca ähm,
denke, Sachsen, Sachsen hat einen guten äh Start gemacht. Ähm Datenschutzkonferenz hatten gute,
Lanze gebrochen für die Corona-Warn-App. Ähm Ulrich Käber äh mit der äh mit der Empfehlung,
dass man jetzt endlich auch in den Infektionsschutzverordnungen
dieser digitalen Möglichkeit Rechnung trägt und nochmal, weil mich die, weil weil ich ja immer wieder gefragt werde, warum ich das gut finde,
wenn man das anonym und dezentral und schnell macht. Ja weil es anonym und dezentral und schnell ist und das habe ich auch in diesem Ausschuss anfangs gesagt, man nimmt sich doch ein Problem.
Und man schaut einfach, wie man das am allerschnellsten gelöst kriegt. Am elegantesten. Und zwar mit der,
mit der zielgerichteten, passenden Lösung. Und mit natürlich kann man immer sagen, wir nehmen einfach eine zentrale Datenbank von allen,
und lassen alle Leute live in unser Ding online einchecken und wenn die offline sind, geht's nicht und so weiter und so fort. Aber das ist dann eben nicht elegant am an dem äh an das,
an dem Problem gearbeitet, weil solange die Benachrichtigung nachher durch Gesundheitsamt,
stattfinden, was irgendwie mit diesen Daten dann arbeiten muss, was potenziell die Daten sortieren soll, ähm wird das halt einfach nur noch,
langsamer.
Und entscheidend ist eben, dass die Sache schneller geht und das schafft in dieser Echtzeit eben nur bisher die Corona-Warn-App und das sogar ohne, dass man irgendwelche Telefonnummern und persönlichen Daten angibt.
Ja, jetzt muss ich zeigen, ob die Politik da auch noch den nächsten Schritt macht und es jetzt nicht nur in
Sachsen so eine latent, zweideutige Meldung dazu gibt, wie man denen das jetzt vielleicht machen kann
sondern dass äh wir jetzt vielleicht auch noch in einem mutigen Schritt einfach auch nochmal die Anerkennung bekommen, dass die staatlich gefördert und eingesetzte Corona-Warn-App mit ihrer Check-In-Funktion auch
diesen Bedarf der Benachrichtigung abdecken kann und dann wäre schon mal eine ganze Menge geholfen. Mein Gott,
Vor allem, wir haben jetzt echt nur noch zwei, drei Monate, die wir durchhalten müssen. Ähm was kann das Problem sein? Na ja.
Es gab übrigens, ach so, eine Sache wollte ich noch äh die kann ich vielleicht noch kurz erwähnen.
Ähm weil ich glaube, dass da eine Frage falsch beantwortet wurde oder oder zumindest.
Also das müsste man mal noch klären. Eine Frage, die sich Leute stellen, ist, was ist denn, wenn jetzt ein Restaurant hast, ne.
Und äh hast du jetzt fünfzig Prozent Gäste, die haben äh ihre Adresse auf einen Zettel geschrieben und fünfzig Prozent Gäste, die haben.
Mit der Corona-Warn-App eingecheckt. Und jetzt löst du aus und zwar eine.
Corona-Warn-App Nutzerin löst aus, dann kriegt natürlich auch die Location die Warnung und dann weiß die Location einfach, alles klar,
Ich gebe jetzt hier die anderen Gäste, die aufm Zettel geschrieben haben, gebe ich jetzt ans Gesundheitsamt, ne? Die müssen dann eben den langsameren Weg gehen. Was ist aber,
andersrum läuft, wenn eine von diesen Zettel Leuten jetzt sagt, hier, Gesundheitsamt und dann sagen die, dann sagt das Gesundheitsamt, oh okay, wo waren sie denn?
Ja da und da und dann merken die auf einmal, ah okay, hier wurde auch die Corona-Warn-App genutzt. Jetzt können wir dann schnell äh schnelle Auslösungen machen. Und da ist es tatsächlich so,
Habe ich mir extra nochmal von der Cameta Thromkoso erklären lassen. Natürlich kann auch die Location auslösen, die Warnung,
Ja? Sie muss nur natürlich irgendwie dazu befähigt werden,
also der Prozess muss da sein, dass jetzt in dem Fall beispielsweise das Gesundheitsamt sagt, okay, hier hast du mal einen TAN,
um bitte auszulösen, damit du die Location.
Jetzt mal gerade die Location als Infektionsfall für diesen Zeitraum in der Corona-Warn-App alarmieren kannst, ne? Weil grundsätzlich kann ja jedes Mitglied,
des Clusters, was diesen QR-Code gescannt hat, die Warnung auslösen, das geht ja.
Und das äh stelle ich mir jetzt die Frage, also nach dem nach der also technisch ist es problemlos möglich. Ähm jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ob die den Prozess dafür haben.
Ähm und das klang gestern so, als hätten sie den noch nicht. Allerdings bin ich mir da irgendwie nicht sicher
der Martin. Die Frage war so ein bisschen komisch gestellt und ob der Martin ich habe die Frage anfangs auch nicht verstanden, ob der Martin Fassungen die verstanden hat oder ob der die richtige Antwort gegeben hat. Ähm
Auf jeden Fall technisch ist es möglich, sollte natürlich auch möglich sein, ne? Das ist ist natürlich entscheidend, dass die Location im Zweifelsfall eben auch dann die Warnung auslösen kann, wenn eine Nicht-Corona-Warnem-Nutzerin.
Da war. Das äh ja, also technisch ist es in dem Konzept vorgesehen. Mir ist noch nicht ganz klar, ob wir in Deutschland den äh Prozess dafür haben.
Genug Corona.
Genug Corona, nee, nee, nee. Wir machen noch weiter mit Corona. Jetzt jetzt kommt erst richtig Corona, Tim.
Jetzt kommt erst richtig Corona. Jetzt kommt Impfpass.
Impfpass, yes.
Das ist oh. Also wir haben ja hier schon bisschen über Impfpässe geredet.
Die Sendung fünf Blockchains äh ist natürlich allen nochmal ans Herz gelegt. Die äh sich mit diesem Thema jetzt erst auseinandersetzen oder die Sendung nicht gehört haben oder sie vielleicht ein bisschen äh weiterempfehlen möchten.
Wir haben damals oder ich habe damals gesagt, für genau dieser Anwendungsfall.
Verteilt im Feld Offline Sachen testen. Will man eigentlich mit elektronischen Signaturen arbeiten? Etwas, was ich glaube, irgendwie durch dieses ganze Blockchain geballert, sind elektronische Signaturen so ähm.
So in Vergessenheit geraten, dass sie weit unter ihrem sexy Missgrad gehandelt werden,
muss man echt einfach mal sagen, also elektronische Signaturen sind eine ziemlich coole Sache oder nicht?
Ja, es ist äh und das auch schon sehr lange so. Das ist halt eigentlich das Ding und sie werden mit Abstand noch nicht so viel genutzt, wie sie genutzt werden könnten.
Und das ist halt jetzt auch hier wieder äh schnell der Fall gewesen, aber das könnte sich jetzt mit dem Impfpass ändern.
Genau, wir haben uns nämlich mal ein bisschen oder ich habe mir mal ein bisschen berichten lassen, was da so mit dem EU-Impfpass geplant ist. Die wollen ja jetzt einen einheitliches.
Soll das ja, glaube ich, heißen. Ähm oder soll das nicht mehr Greensert heißen, soll es anders heißen, wie auch immer. Also wir wollen eine EU weiten ähm Impfpass,
haben und zwar in digitaler Form.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, das ist auch wirklich langfristig geplant als einen Nachweis für alle Impfungen. Es geht hier nicht nur um Corona
Das geht auch um Corona und vor allem erstmal primär natürlich um Corona, aber grundsätzlich ist das eben auch eine langfristige Strategie, wie man Impfungen an sich nachweisen kann.
Ich da würde ich jetzt vorsichtig erstmal widersprechen, weil es geht jetzt schon sehr konkret hier um äh Corona.
Ja, es geht jetzt, das meine ich ja auch. Es geht jetzt erst mal um um Corona, aber das Ganze ist schon immer geplant gewesen als eine langfristige Digitalisierung des Impfnachweises.
Ja, aber also komm, das ist schon relativ klar, die wollen bis zum zwanzigsten Mai das Ding fertig verhandelt haben. Im Juni, im Plenum, im Juli, am laufen. Das geht jetzt nicht um eine grundsätzliche Impfnachweise, sondern es geht sehr genau um ein
äh Corona.
Ja, das ist das Ziel, aber es ist nicht darauf beschränkt.
Okay. Ähm.
Sie haben sich entschieden, ein System zu bauen, was äh mit einer äh Publicy Infrastructure arbeitet, also mit äh das heißt also, man hat immer ein.
Ähm man hat quasi müssen wir mal elektronische Signaturen eigentlich erklären, ne, ohne ohne eine elektronische Signatur zu erklären kriegt man das nicht hin. Ähm.
Da muss man auch natürlich Public und Pravit Kiefer fahren noch mal kurz ansprechen.
Das müssen wir machen, ja. Okay, kriege ich hin. Ähm.
Kryptographie. Das ist so eine Sache.
Die Kryptographie. Es gibt die symmetrische Kryptographie. Das wäre etwas, wo man sagt, der Schlüssel,
wird quasi, ist beim Verschlüsseln und beim Entschlüsseln der Gleiche. Ja, das ist, so werden die meisten,
Dinge verschlüsselt, wenn wir eine Festplatte habt, dann wird die mit wird die symmetrisch verschlüsselt, ne, das heißt, aller Datenstrom wird mit einem Key verschlüsselt und mit dem gleichen Key wird der auch wieder gelesen.
Weil's für einen selbst ist. Man will das ja, man will ja auch selber wieder ran an die Daten. Deswegen vergibt man sich einmal dafür ein Passwort und das ist dann eben der Schlüssel, um's auch wieder auszupacken. So wie man's erwarten würde.
Wenn man aber die ganze Zeit symmetrisch verschlüsselt, hat man ein Problem, nämlich man
man kann ja quasi über die Distanz, wenn man Initial eine Verbindung herstellt oder so, nicht diesen Schlüssel übertragen,
und dieses Problem wurde sehr schön gelöst und viele andere Probleme durch eine der größten Erfindungen in der in der IT und in der IT-Sicherheit, nämlich.
Asymmetrische Verschlüsselung. Und die müsst ihr euch vorstellen.
Ich mache, fangen wir vereinfacht an, wie ein Vorhängeschloss.
Ein Schlüssel. Das Vorhängeschloss gebe ich dem Tim.
Der schreibt seine Nachricht, macht ihn mit dem Vorhängeschloss zu. Und in diesem Moment kann er die nicht mehr öffnen.
Er weiß zwar, was da drin ist. Er hat's ja selber da rein geschrieben, aber er kriegt sie nicht mehr auf, weil ihm der Schlüssel fehlt, um dieses Vorhängeschloss,
zu öffnen. Den habe nur ich.
Für das nur du den Schlüssel hast, genau. Mhm.
Und das ist genau dieser Unterschied mit dem.
Öffentlichen Schlüssel, der ist ein sehr verwirrendes, sehr verwirrender Begriff, weil öffentlicher Schlüssel, was heißt das, ne? Aber es äh es gibt den den öffentlichen Teil und wenn man an diesen öffentlichen Teil verschlüsselt,
Dann kann man mit dem geheimen Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Und.
So weit können wir die Leute immer noch folgen. Jetzt ist es so.
Es ergibt sich ein neues Problem. Wenn der Tim jetzt irgendwie am anderen Ende des Planeten ist.
Und ich möchte mit dem verschlüsselt kommunizieren und wir uns davor sorgen, dass zwischen uns etwas ist, was mithört und potenziell auch mit manipulieren kann. Dann hätten wir die Sorge,
dass der,
Tim mir zwar seinen Schluss, sein Schloss schickt, dass unterwegs aber von jemand anders ausgetauscht wird, ich das falsche Schloss nutze, die gleiche Person dann wieder quasi umschlüsselt und in der Mitte sitzt und mitschreibt.
Also wie kann man sicherstellen, dass man auch das richtige Vorhängeschloss bekommen hat?
Genau, wie kann man sicherstellen, dass man auch das richtige Feuergeschloss bekommen hat? Und,
Das ist die Sorge oder das ist das Problem, was Signaturen lösen können. Die können aber noch was ganz anderes lösen. Sie können nämlich zum Beispiel auch äh tatsächlich die rechtsverbindliche Signatur darstellen. Doch
Fangen wir einfach an. Der Tim nimmt jetzt eine Nachricht an mich, schreibt mir etwas.
Und ähm sagte hier hallo Linus, äh so und so und er möchte jetzt beweisen, dass er diese Nachricht geschickt hat. Jetzt macht er im Prinzip eine Verschlüsselungsoperation mit seinem.
Secret key, also mit dem Schlüssel.
Und diese Verschlüsselungsoperation kann ich nachher verifizieren anhand des öffentlichen Schlüssels. Also er kann mir quasi jetzt beweisen,
oder ich kann prüfen, dass er eine Bitfolge signiert hat mit seinem Secret Key.
Weil ich sein Publicy kenne. Und das klingt jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen äh ähm schwer nachvollziehbar, aber es hat eine äh es hat wirklich,
wichtige Konsequenzen in in der IT-Sicherheit, diese Signatur, denn wenn der Tim eine Nachricht signiert.
Mit seinen. Und schicke die an mich. Und an dieser Nachricht ändert sich auch nur ein Bit.
Dann schlägt bei mir die Signaturprüfung mit seinem Publicy fehl. Und dadurch weiß ich, dass hier etwas verändert wurde. Der Tim hat nicht diese Nachricht signiert, die bei mir angekommen ist.
Und.
Ne, also es gibt Verschlüsselungen und es gibt Signatur. Verschlüsselung kommt bei diesen EU äh Passsystemen, bei diesen Impfpasssystemen eigentlich gar nicht zum Tragen. Es kommt eigentlich immer nur die Signatur zum Tragen. Denn.
Jetzt pass auf.
Nehmen wir einmal an, es gibt ein Schlüsselpaar, von dem ich wüsste, dass es einer Ärztin gehört. Und wenn diese Ärztin jetzt den Datensatz signiert.
Tim wurde dann und dann mit dem und dem Impfstoff geimpft.
Dann bräuchte ich ja nur den öffentlichen Schlüssel dieser Ärztin, um mit.
Quasi prüfen zu können, dass diese Signatur von der Ärztin angebracht wurde.
Ne? Weil man kann ja mit seinem Secret Key Sachen signieren. Also müsste, bräuchte ich den den öffentlichen Schlüssel der Ärztin und könnte sehen, aha, okay, das ist äh ein Impfausweis für Tim.
Jetzt gibt's aber ein weiteres Problem. Es gibt viel zu viele Ärztinnen.
Und woher weiß ich überhaupt, ob diese Ärztin eine echte Ärztin ist und berechtigt ist, Impfausweise auszustellen?
Deswegen baut man jetzt da drüber einfach nochmal genau das Gleiche, also über den öffentlichen Schlüssel der Ärztin gibt es jetzt eine Signatur von einer höher liegenden Instanz, die sagt, diese Ärztin darf übrigens Impfausweise ausstellen.
Und diese höher liegende Instanz kann jetzt zum Beispiel so etwas sein, wie ich spinne jetzt mal rum, ne. Das könnte jetzt, was weiß ich, das Land Berlin sein oder äh die Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder was weiß ich, ähm.
Die das Gesundheitsamt von Berlin Mitte. Und die hätten dann auch wieder irgendeine Berechtigung und am Ende diese Berechtigungskette.
Berechtigt eine Signatur auszustellen.
Läuft dann irgendwann hoch, bis auf die äh auf ein Wurzelzertifikat oder mehrere Wurzelzertifikate, die dann zum Beispiel der Europäischen Union,
oder ähm ihren sechzehn Mitgliedstaaten gehören,
Das heißt, man würde, wenn man das Modell von oben schaut, wahrscheinlich am Ende ein EU-Impfpassschlüssel haben und der stellt erstmal äh für jeden Mitgliedsstaat eine äh,
Autorität aus, die wiederum quasi das Recht, Impfausweise zu unterzeichnen, weitergeben darf.
Und so hat man dann bei jedem einzelnen Impfnachweis eine Signaturkette, die sich nachprüfen lässt bis zu letztendlich.
Der europäischen Union. Und zwar offline. Weitest gehend offline. Das ist das Geile daran.
Genau. Darauf wollte ich auch gerade zu sprechen kommen. Also das ist eigentlich das das Wunder eigentlich dieser äh asymmetrischen
Verschlüsselungstechnologie, die eben im Prinzip zwei äh Dinge äh ermöglicht, nämlich diese digitalen Unterschriften und eben auch so dieses Versenden von von verschlüsselten Nachrichten,
Man kann sich das ja im richtigen Leben auch vorstellen, ja. Die oberste Behörde äh
gründet eine unterliegende Behörde und stellt der ein Zertifikat auf, was dann da irgendwie an der Wand hängt. Und die hat dann wiederum ihre Nebenstellen und äh da hängt dann auch ein Zertifikat äh an der Wand, die immer wieder schön bestätigt mit Unterschriften vom Chef.
Dass das schon so richtig passt. Und dann geht das halt immer so weiter, bis eben zu dieser Zulassung des äh der Ärztin, die äh dann eben der Patientin irgendwie diese Impfung verabreicht,
Das Schöne ist, dass man in diesem in diesem digitalen Kettenmodell all diese ganzen miteinander verketteten Informationen in einem kleinen Stück,
Datenblock zusammenfassen kann und extrem zuverlässig,
überprüfen kann. Und das macht es eigentlich so elegant. Und wie du schon sagtest, das sind dann keine Online-Abfragen, wo dann so, oh, ich gucke mir das mal an, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen und jetzt muss ich mich hier zu Server XY und auch in dreißig Blockchains.
Genau, ne? Das ist alles nicht nötig, weil sich das quasi
automatisch einfach aus den Daten selbst heraus ergibt. Man kann es einfach ausrechnen, dass es stimmt. Und es gibt,
immer noch so eine Onlinekomponente, mit der man dann sagen wir mal, irgend so ein,
irgendeine Ärztin äh in dieser Kette ist dann auf einmal dafür bekannt geworden, Impfungen zertifiziert zu haben, die gar nicht stattgefunden haben,
könnte eben deren Zertifikat
zurückgerufen werden. Das ist dann tatsächlich eine Online verfügbare Information, wo man von Zeit zu Zeit mal nachfragt. So, hör mal, sind vielleicht irgendwelche Zertifikate, die da draußen herausgegeben wurden, ungültig geworden,
dann merke ich mir das mal,
Und dann kann man diese Information auch zwischenspeichern und wenn man dann eben auf so ein Zertifikat trifft, was eben mit so einer fragwürdigen äh Person in Zusammenhang steht, dann sieht man halt immer noch so, aber hier, ich habe vor einer Woche schon äh gehört,
gilt nicht mehr, deswegen reicht das jetzt nicht mehr anerkennen.
Und das Schöne ist, das kannst du auf jeder Ebene dieser Hierarchie machen. Du könntest äh einzelne Impfausweise und äh ganze Länder.
Das ganze Bundesgesundheitsministerium wird einfach dislabelt, genau. Wird ersetzt wegen Inkompetenz.
So und der Rest nach diesem ganzen CA, wenn man da, wenn man das jetzt mal als gegeben annimmt, ich
Also ich weiß, dass es lange dauert, bis man das wirklich vollständig verstanden hat, aber also eine kryptographische Signatur hat eben den wunderschönen Teil, dass sie eben nicht fälschbar ist und dass sie ähm
ne, sobald du auch nur ein Bit änderst, stimmt immer die Signatur nicht mehr,
Ne, man kann die nicht einfach da drunter kopieren, sondern die ist letztendlich eine Prüfsumme über den Inhalt.
Und jetzt würde man damit zum Beispiel folgendes machen, ähm,
Und das ist auch hier vorgesehen. Sie wollen PCR-Test, Schnelltest, Genesung und Impfung.
Als Datentypen haben. Und die sollen gleichgestellt sein in der Behandlung.
Diejenigen, die die Zertifikate ausstellen, dürfen die nur so lange behalten, wie die Zertifikate gültig sind.
Also falls du es verlierst, kannst du es im Rahmen der Gültigkeit noch zurückbekommen. Ähm.
Und jetzt kommen natürlich so die Sachen, wir haben jetzt gerade gesagt, diese Zertifikate kannst du halt offline prüfen, was ein total wichtiger Skalierungsfrage ist, ne. Wenn du jetzt sagst, du machst den Deutschen
Impfpass, ja? Und jedes Mal, wenn irgendein blöder Impfpass gescannt wird, muss, muss irgendein von,
gefragt werden und in angeblich in der Blockchain nachgucken, was die ja dann natürlich nicht machen,
ne? Wäre der viel zu intensiv, viel zu rechnen intensiv da jedes Mal eine Blockchain abzufragen.
Dann kannst du eben ähm kannst du kannst du Info in Kleßen-Görne kannst du halt dann.
Kannst du keine Impfzwang machen, ne? Und kein Ecken. So, dieses Problem lösen sie damit, ja? So,
ähm genau. Jetzt sagen sie äh die, also wer auch immer jetzt quasi deinen Impfpass scannt.
Darf, einfach nicht die Daten, die da stehen, aufbewahren und weiterverarbeiten. Wird einfach grundsätzlich verboten. Der wird nur, du darfst nur einmal äh checken.
Das ist auch notwendig, denn wir haben ja in einer früheren Sendung schon gesagt, so dass wahrscheinlich würde ich da Geburtsdatum und was weiß ich, letzte,
zig Ziffern der Personalausweisnummer rein tun. Da kam aber natürlich auch Einwände. Das potenziell ja auch Ausweise aus auslaufen.
Ähm nach jetzigem Stand soll dieser EU-Impfpass deshalb Name und Geburtsdatum ähm die Daten über.
Test, Schnelltest, äh Genesung oder Impfung,
Ausstellungsdatum, also wann es wann dieses digitale Ding ausgestellt wurde, sowie ähm die,
Daten, wann hier diese Impfungen und so weiter stattgefunden haben und wie lange die gültig sind. Ne, dass also dass dann da drin steht, Schnelltestform und dein guckt dann eben drauf und sieht, ah okay, ne. Das Zertifikat ist ähm,
Das ist nur vierundzwanzig Stunden gültig, falls ein Schnelltest ist ähm oder in dem Fall einer Impfung ist das Zertifikat von mir aus vier Jahre gültig, aber den kann irgendwann weiß der halt, na ja,
Impfung, die hat ja nur äh vier Monate gehalten. Äh insofern ist die jetzt quasi ist der Status, dass diese Person geimpft ist oder äh immun ist für mich schon wieder,
nicht mehr relevant.
Tim hat das gerade schon angesprochen, die Revocation, also die ungültigmachung, macht man mit sogenannten Revocation-List. Das sind im Prinzip einfach auch wieder nur signierte Listen von,
Existierenden Zertifikaten, wo eine höher gesetzte Offeritie sagt übrigens, die sind nicht mehr gültig. Und das ist auch wieder nur eine signierte,
Liste. So, das haben sie sich jetzt äh überlegt für die EU,
und technisch macht das einen soliden Eindruck. Ich sage jetzt nochmal, ich rede jetzt hier nur von der Technik. Ich möchte von der gesellschaftlichen Komponente,
bewusst nachher sprechen. Die großen Probleme sind jetzt erstmal weg, wie zum Beispiel, dass irgendwo eine zentrale Infrastruktur ist, die die ganze Zeit trackt
man kann natürlich immer diese Daten aussehen. Es ist super einfach ein Impfpasscanner dann zu bauen, der die Daten, die da drin steht, speichert und einfach weiß, der und der war hier, ne? Das ist ein
das ist ein Risiko, was hierbei eine Rolle spielt. Deswegen finde ich das natürlich auch sehr sinnvoll, dass die sofort sagen, das muss einfach verboten sein. So, weil es, weil es geht, wir können's einfach nur illegal machen, mehr geht nicht.
Das muss ja dann auch in den Staaten umgesetzt werden und das heißt eben auch, dass jegliche privaten Ziele so etwas zu speichern, eben Strafe wert sind und die die Mitgliedstaaten das einfach auch nicht machen dürfen. Das scheint mir,
schon ganz äh äh sinnvoll zu sein. Jetzt ist aber, kommen wir langsam in den Teil, was soll das denn machen?
So und da diskutieren die jetzt natürlich auf der EU-Ebene. Reicht das für die komplette Schengen-Reise-Freiheit oder keiner in Einzelstaat noch etwas verhängen? Die Position der Kommission ist ungefähr.
Wenn du irgendetwas noch einschränken willst an Reisefreiheit und das an irgendetwas binden willst, dann muss es an etwas sein, was in diesem.
Zertifikat ist. Das Parlament will äh Schengen-Reisefreiheit haben und der Rat,
vermutlich so drauf, dass die sagen, boah, wisst ihr, ey, wenn wenn wir auf einmal wissen, dass die französischen Antigentests mist sind, ne? Oder in,
Tschechien eine neue Mutation ausbricht, dann wollen wir potenziell eben auch
ja, an der an der äh Mitgliedsstaatengrenze äh diskriminieren können, ne? Oder zumachen können oder bestimmte Tests oder bestimmte Impfungen nicht akzeptieren. Und ähm vermutlich werden sie sich
im Prinzip darauf einigen, dass man sagt, okay, du kannst deine eigenen Regeln machen,
aber die müssen innerhalb des Staates die gleichen sein wie an den äh Schengengrenzen,
dann diskutieren sie noch so ein bisschen, welche Impfungen man halt anerkennt, das wird natürlich auch ein Problem sein, äh weil ähm.
Wie wir wissen, gibt es das Paul Ehrlich-Institut in Deutschland. Dann gibt's die EMA auf europäischer Ebene, dann gibt's irgendwie offenbar Ungarn impft schon mit Sputnik.
Was aber jetzt auf was noch nicht immer zertifiziert ist, oder?
Richtig. Und wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirt.
Und dann hättest du,
jetzt hättest du also ein Problem, dass müssen sie sich jetzt eben auskäsen, was passiert, äh wenn jetzt die ganzen äh Ungarn
die Sputnik geimpften Ungaren ähm nach Berlin kommen wollen.
Ähm und hier sputnik, anerkentwert oder nicht anerkannt wird, ne? Über solche Sachen machen die sich natürlich dann auch noch Gedanken glücklicherweise, nicht die Gedanken, die wir uns machen müssen.
Dann sagen sie die Diskriminierungsfreiheit zwischen Test, Genesung und Impfung schreiben sie fest. Also.
Wenn du geimpft bist, muss das gleiche Level an Privileg mit,
Test erreichbar sein. Das Problem ist aber natürlich, dass diese Tests ja Geld kosten potenziell. Und hm,
daraus schließen sie dann zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt der Test eine Reiseauflage ist, dann muss der natürlich auch kostenlos sein.
Das einzig Positive, was ich daran sehe ist, solange der Test kostenlos angeboten werden, muss, ich meine, ein Test ist ja fast so teuer wie eine Impfung, ne. Habe ich das richtig gehört bei euch in in UKW-Tim?
Die kann man, ja, also es kommt jetzt ein bisschen darauf an, was man insgesamt alles noch zu den Kosten der Impfung mit dazuzählt. Also du hast natürlich die Kosten für die äh Dosis an sich,
an den Hersteller, aber du musst ja auch noch die ganze Logistik dazudenken. Also sowohl bei den ausführenden äh Entitäten als eben auch das Versenden zu Stellenplanen und so weiter, also die Kosten für eine einzelne Impfung sind sicherlich auch nicht gering,
das äh unterm Strich dann mehr ist als ein PCR-Test, kann ich nicht sagen. Ich,
fast vermuten, das liegt so in etwa im gleichen Bereich. Vielleicht sind die PCR das billiger mittlerweile.
Also ich es ist ja immer so die Sache ist ja ich glaube natürlich ist ein PCR-Test billiger als eine Impfung ähm
aber die Frage ist ja, was das BMG gerade dafür bezahlt und die haben oder was was die
Berater von Jens Spahn gegoogelt haben, ne? Und äh die die Schnelltests werden ja gerade sehr fürstlich bezahlt. Deswegen schießen ja auch überall diese Schnelltesten aus dem Boden. Ähm,
Auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass ein, also jemand, der einen Monat lang andauernd getestet wird, der reißt hier ein größeres Loch in die Tasche als jemand, der einmal geimpft wurde.
Und das ist, was also hoffentlich heißt, dass es einen finanziellen Anreiz gibt, möglichst äh schnell die Leute durchzuimpfen. Ähm.
Also gesellschaftlich ist es natürlich das Impfen auf jeden Fall das das Beste, weil Infektion ist äh mit Abstand das teuerste.
Genau. So, dann gab es jetzt eine längere Debatte darüber oder auch medialer Form und damit kommen wir jetzt langsam zu dem gesellschaftlichen Bereich. Das nämlich.
Den Leuten aufgefallen ist, hm irgendwie impfen wir ja schon eine Zeit lang und irgendwie sind ja auch jetzt schon ein paar Leute geimpft.
Ähm in Deutschland waren sie als das letzte Mal geguckt habe acht Prozent durchgeimpft, zwanzig Prozent Erstgeimpft oder so, ne, in dieser Region bewegt sich das.
Wir haben jetzt dreißig Prozent äh Erstgeimpfte, acht Prozent Zweitkämpfte.
Okay und die haben alle einen relativ simplen Aufkleber in ihrem WHO-Impfpaß drin.
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie impfen, wie wie upgraden wir die denn jetzt? Auf unser Supersecure Digitalding.
Und die Antwort ist natürlich, das wird euch im Zweifelsfall nicht gelingen. Ähm angeblich.
Kann das immer nicht beurteilen, aber sagen wir mal so, irgendjemand wird sicherlich schon so einen Impfpass gefälscht haben, ob das jetzt so ein riesen Markt im Darknet ist, wie alle immer behaupten.
Weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht beurteilen, ist mir irgendwie also ne, das sind alles keine verifizierten Verkäufe. Ähm aber sagen wir mal, das Problem existiert, wie groß es ist, ist es eigentlich unerheblich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch. Denn.
So schön digital und unfälsch bei dieser äh Impfpass dann sein wird, werden, glaube ich, die gesellschaftlichen Probleme anderer sein. Erstens, ja, man kann ihn fälschen und zwar, weil man auf diesen sicheren, digitalen Impfpass im Moment,
so wie es aussieht upgradet durch ein Stück Papier mit einem kleinen Aufkleber drauf. Und da halt diese Aufkleber niemals gebaut wurden, um fälschungssicher zu sein, ähm sind die halt auch sehr einfach zu,
reproduzieren.
Das ist noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob das so sein wird. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du da schon konkret was zu gelesen hast. Ich vermute allerdings, das als
Ausweis, die Dinger. Zunächst einmal ein sind, bis man irgendwann an einem Punkt angekommen ist, wo man sagen kann, ab jetzt gilt eigentlich nur noch der digitale, weil jetzt müsste ja jeder einen haben.
Das ist der andere Punkt, also die Frage ist ja, warum baust du so ein digitales Ding? Und der einzige Grund ist,
Der einzige Grund das zu tun ist, weil du viele und schnelle Checks erwartest.
Und zwar über einen längeren Zeitraum. Das ist der einzige Grund, der gegen die.
WHO Hefte äh spricht, ist, wenn man jetzt sagt, alles klar, du musst das Ding die ganze Zeit dabei haben und andauernd zeigen, dann fallen die halt innerhalb kürzester Zeit auseinander. Weil die einfach nicht für einen täglichen Einsatz gebaut sind.
Nicht nur viele, sondern halt auch online unter Umständen.
Genau und und also online, ja online mag auch eine Rolle spielen, klar wird wird auch eine Rolle spielen
Reisebuchung und so, also in diese Gespräche ist auch sind ist natürlich so die IATA äh und die WHO äh involviert, ne, also die Flug äh
die sich um die Fluggeschichten auch kümmern, weil die natürlich auch daran interessiert sind, dass ihnen ein potenzielle.
Die potentielle Auflage Impf oder Testnachweise zu prüfen, möglichst wenig in die in die existierenden Prozesse,
reingrätscht. Aber letztendlich trotzdem, du baust das, damit es oft genutzt wird. Und von mir aus auch über die Distanz. Und.
Ich stelle mir folgendes Szenario vor. Wie viel die Dinger tatsächlich gefälscht werden.
Hängt einfach nur von einer Sache ab.
Wie hoch ist der Druck, dass Leute, die fälschen wollen und der Druck ist eigentlich nur dadurch hoch.
Wenn du den Leuten mit diesem Impfpass sehr viel größere Vorteile einräumst als ohne.
Und sei der Nachteil nur, dass du, wenn du wenn du am Wochenende feiern gehen willst, jeden Morgen dir irgendeinen Stab in die Nase stecken lassen muss. Sei auch sei er auch kostenlos. Das ist das eine Ding. Ähm.
Das wird also die Leute motivieren, den zu fälschen. Das andere ist, wenn das jetzt hier zum Beispiel an der Kneipe oder so
eine Rolle spielt. Ja, gehen wir mal von den von so Situationen wie Fußballstadien oder Flug weg, wo du auch wirklich namentlich registriert bist, ne? Gehen wir mal zu wirklich einfachen Situationen, Einlasssituationen irgendwo, dem man Restaurant?
Da steht dann eine Person am Einlass, die da wahrscheinlich für Mindestlohn steht.
Und die wird für ihre acht Euro fünfzig die Stunde ähm auf so ein Display gucken und darauf achten, dass das da grün leuchtet.
Und da Vietname stehen und ein Geburtsdatum und dann wird die vielleicht noch so sich die Mühe machen, darauf gucken, dass das vom Geburtsjahrzehnt ungefähr hinkommt.
Und vielleicht auch, dass der Vorname irgendwie zur Geschlechtsidentität zu passen scheint, grob. Aber irgendeine ähm.
Die diesen Job machen muss, wird sich dort nicht mit irgendjemandem anlegen oder irgendwie großartig Ausweise kontrollieren, ähm.
Am Eingang von irgendeiner Kneipe. Da wird das Typische kommen, hör mal,
Kalle, du weißt doch, ich ich habe ich habe dir doch gestern erzählt, dass sie mich heute wieder testen lasse. Außer du weißt doch, ich bin geimpft. Also, dass wir, ich glaube, der wird einfach nicht in der Form entforst werden wie die sich das vorstellen.
Und deswegen glaube ich ähm.
Tja, dass das viele Leute ganz einfach den den äh QR-Code von was weiß ich, von irgendjemand anders da dran halten und sagen, yo, ich bin das, ich habe meinen Ausweis nicht dabei.
Ne? Also das ist das sind die Realweltumgehungen, die bei solchen Systemen stattfinden,
werden. Wäre jetzt so meine Schätzung. Und da sind wir dann wirklich auch bei dem äh gesellschaftlichen Problem. Da kannst du mir jetzt gleich weiterhelfen, Tim, ich schätze das irgendwie so wann ist das August oder September?
Sind fünfzig Prozent der Leute durchgeimpft und die anderen fünfzig nicht.
In Deutschland, also durchgeimpft kann ich dir jetzt gerade, also meinst, im Sinne von Zweitimpfung abgeschlossen,
Das dürfte äh frühestens ähm,
Also wenn's richtig gut läuft, Ende Juli,
im Laufe des Augusts dürften wir sowas wie fünfzig Prozent Zweidimpfung haben. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen aus dem Bauch heraus gesagt, aber ich glaube, das ist äh ganz realistisch. Wenn's so läuft, wie es jetzt läuft.
Vorbehaltlich von vielen Lieferzusagen, die eingehalten werden müssen und äh Impfstoffen, die noch zugelassen werden müssen und äh,
politischen Problemen, die die das alles noch einschränkt, ne. Soll ja zum Beispiel noch mit dazustoßen, damit wird geplant, aber die kriegen derzeit nicht genug ähm Material ran, was die USA blockiert und so weiter. Also das sind alles so
politische Schwierigkeiten, die noch überwunden werden müssen, aber wir werden jetzt bei den Erstimpfungen zumindest relativ schnell da sein, so eine Monate ungefähr.
So und das äh.
Also, ich glaube, das wird, das wird relativ unangenehm. Ich glaube wirklich, dass die da äh also die die realistische,
das realistische Ergebnis kann eigentlich nur entweder sein, du wirst richtig fett werden die Leute sich diese Dinger fälschen. Ähm.
Oder es wird irgendwie das das Regime, das zu kontrollieren und aufrechtzuerhalten bricht einfach in sich zusammen.
Und ich glaube, darauf steuern die hin. Dass das nämlich wirklich kontrolliert, nicht entforst wird,
dieser Impf die Impfprivilegien, die man noch obendrauf kriegt und,
das ist deswegen tragisch, weil das am Ende diejenigen, die Gesundheit kosten wird, die da draußen das Tralaffitti sehen, noch nicht geimpft sind und sich dann eben sich und andere in Gefahr bringen.
Und dass wir trotzdem dann eine niedrige Inzidenz sein, weil fünfzig Prozent der Leute sind ja geimpft und die Ungeimpften werden dann halt, was weiß ich, aus ihrer Not ähm
ja, sie potenziell ähm sehr ohne viel Aufwand
die Kontrollen auch umgehen, weil sie sowieso nicht ernstzunehmend sind, weil sie eben von irgendwelchen Leuten gemacht werden, die sich auch überlegen, ob sie sich jetzt einen harten Tag bei der Arbeit machen oder nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, das realistische Szenario
was passieren wird,
dass man sagt, ja ja, wir haben den Impfnachweis hier, gucken wir drauf mit den Tests und grün und blau und rot und haste nicht gesehen. Das System zwar digital komplett,
dicht ist, aber eben für die Situation trotzdem nicht geschaffen ist.
Und ähm dann wird's wahrscheinlich am Ende,
ähm einfach nur dazu führen, dass dass dass es massiv umgangen wird, aber die, die es umgehen, tun's eben um nur mit der Konsequenz, sich selber zu schaden. Und da wird man dann sagen, ja, bist du halt selber schuld.
Ja, also,
Vielleicht sollte man nochmal so ein etwas konzentrierteren Blick auf die realistische Timeline von diesem Ganzen mal werfen. Äh weil wir haben ja verschiedene Systeme, die zusammen
greifen müssen, damit man überhaupt erstmal an so einen Punkt kommen kann, äh dass man sagt, okay, jetzt haben wir einen äh Impfnachweis, jetzt kann der von Leuten auch benutzt werden,
Und eigentlich kann der auch erst in dem Moment benutzt werden, wo auch alle, die Geimpft sind, eine Chance haben.
Den auch wirklich benutzen zu können, ja?
Kann ja jetzt nicht sein, dass man irgendwas nachweisen soll, aber die die Voraussetzungen für das Nachweisen ist noch gar nicht gegeben.
Dann wird man immer natürlich äh argumentieren, naja gut, aber im im Zweifelsfall hast du halt den normalen Standard-WHO äh das Impfbuch,
das reicht dann auch, ja? Solange das aber so ist, kann man auch sagen, existiert halt dieser digitale Impfpass eigentlich gar nicht
Ja, weil wenn er nur,
ist und so, aber man als alternativ auch immer noch den Rechtsanspruch hat mit dem gelben Buch zu wählen, ist das Ding im Prinzip hinfällig. Also letztlich ist der entscheidende Zeitpunkt
der wo gesagt wird, okay äh alles ist jetzt am Start, Leute. Äh ab jetzt nur noch mit diesem Digitalen,
Impfpass. Bloß das wird dann halt jedes Gericht stoppen, was äh eine Klage reinkriegt la äh Leute äh es haben noch nicht alle Leute die Möglichkeit, denen überhaupt
ordnungsgemäß zum Einsatz zu bringen. Ihr könnt unmöglich irgendwelche Rechte davon abhängig machen, wenn ihr eben
technisch noch überhaupt nicht die Voraussetzung dafür geschaffen hat, dass er auch wirklich so benutzt werden kann, wie er das gerne möchte, dass er benutzt wird,
Und um an diesem Punkt überhaupt zu kommen, muss jetzt natürlich erstmal,
Das Ding muss natürlich jetzt erstmal durchspezifiziert sein. Wir befinden uns jetzt gerade an einem Punkt, wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind die Diskussionen, die politischen Diskussionen im Parlament sind, die jetzt schon abgeschlossen oder sind die kurz davor abgeschlossen zu werden? Was ist dein Eindruck?
Auf EU-Ebene.
Ähm die werden sollen dann eben zum Moment, ich hatte mir alles erklärt. Ich scrolle gerade wild durch meine Notizen ähm,
Also zwanzigster Mai soll das fertig verhandelt sein. Das ist in vierzehn Tag.
Gut, also sagen wir mal,
ab Juni weiß man, was implementiert werden muss. Sicherlich wird an vielen technischen Dingen, die dann jetzt auch erforderlich sind, auch schon geschraubt. Aber was brauchen wir? Wir brauchen diese Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, von der wir gesprochen haben,
Sowas ist sicherlich ein Teil hier und da schon in irgendeiner Form auch im Betrieb, aber es muss natürlich dann für diesen Zweck auch ganz konkret in dieser äh Ausformung muss es da sein. Es muss äh gekoppelt werden mit diesen ganzen Zertifikaten für alle,
Alle Entitäten, die in irgendeiner Form Impfung bestätigen, muss es äh,
muss es vorhanden sein. Jede Arztpraxis in Deutschland, jede Arztpraxis in Europa, jede muss über einen entsprechendes, signiertes Zertifikat ähm verfügen. Wir reden über.
Zigtausende Arztpraxen überall in siebenundzwanzig Mitgliedsländern.
Na da würde ich kurz äh Einspruch erheben.
Ja, mach mal.
Die werden also die werden im Zweifelsfall über irgendwelche äh Dienst
Leister das abfackeln. Es wird nicht jede einzelne Arztpraxis eine Signatur Karte haben
zum ähm Impfnachweise ausstellen, sondern das wird doch dann wieder so laufen, dass dann, was weiß ich, die kassenärztliche Vereinigung irgendwie so ein Service laufen hat oder irgendein
Anbieter, dass das regelt. Der unterhält dann vielleicht sogar eine eigene äh
ein eigenes Zertifikat für jede Praxis, aber der fackelt dann mal eben die die Signaturdinger da ab.
Gut, dann stellt sich aber im Prinzip nämlich die nächste Frage, wenn es nicht an den Orten gemacht wird zum Zeitpunkt der Impfung, von den Leuten, die das tun.
Von wem wird es dann gemacht? Auf Basis welcher Daten, zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Kann ja nur der Impfausweis sein, der existierende.
Ja, aber wenn der existierende Impfausweis mit all seiner Fälschbarkeit.
Jetzt sozusagen die Grundlage ist, dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wer checkt denn dann in zwei Monaten fünfzig Millionen,
gelbe Zettel in Deutschland
Behörde, welche Entität blättert sich durch diesen Blätterwald? Teil einfach mal die Anzahl von Personen, die das dann sozusagen betrifft. Das ist jetzt aber im zurückhaltenden Fall, sind es nur die Zweitgeimpften,
Plus die da halt irgendwie Johnson und Johnson gehabt haben. So, gut, dann sind es vielleicht nur dreißig Prozent der deutschen Bevölkerung. Aber es sind auch dreißig Prozent der europäischen Bevölkerung.
Müssen jetzt alle irgendwo hingehen, wo sie sich das bestätigen lassen von jemanden, der das machen kann. Wer soll das sein? Die Filiale der Krankenkassen.
Apotheken.
Wo kriegen die dann ihr Zertifikat her? Haben die so viel Zeit? Teile einfach mal die Person, der Leute, solange wie das dauert plus technische Probleme. Einfach nur mal die die pure,
Anzahl der Personen in Deutschland, die manuell, wo so ein Ding überprüft werden muss, wo du die Chargen nochmal überprüfen musst, wo du überprüfen musst, ob die,
Signatur stimmt, das ist diese diese äh Ärztin gibt, die da äh eingetragen ist,
nachgefragt werden. Dann sind die Zweitimpfung mal woanders statt. Also das ist halt alles nicht besonders perfekt äh dokumentiert, dann kannst du den Stempel nicht lesen und so weiter. Also dass dieser.
Ausweis, wirklich die das Bootstrapping ist für den digitalen Ausweis, da habe ich einfach meine Zweifel. So
wenn der das nicht ist, wollen wir jetzt einfach mal sagen, aus diesen Überlegungen heraus ist das einfach nicht leistbar und das würde ich, würde ich fast sagen, dass das nicht leistbar ist, dann,
muss dann doch wiederum der eigentliche Impfort die Quelle sein.
Was haben wir da für Orte? Wir haben das Impfzentrum oder die Impfzentren? Wir haben die Hausärzte, die beteiligt sind und dann haben wir noch so ein äh diese mobilen Teams.
Deutsches Rotes Kreuz und so weiter, die äh in Altersheimen unterwegs waren und die haben halt alle in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Dokumentation,
Was es aber nicht gibt, ist,
Es gibt kein zentrales Impfregister. Das ist etwas, was wohl im Dezember vom Spahn angeregt wurde. Ich habe sowas gelesen wie das RKI wurde beauftragt, sowas mal zu entwickeln. Aber existieren tut es nicht.
So, das heißt, alle Impfungen, die bisher abgelaufen sind, sind nicht zentral gespeichert.
Sondern sie sind gespeichert in den digitalen Lösungen, die die Impfzentren benutzen. Da hast du hier irgendwie das Doktor Lip System für die Impfzentren in Berlin, dann hast du halt äh Eventim, was ist das,
Ist auch die Frage, ist das jetzt mit dieser Terminplanungssoftware das gleiche oder sind das nochmal separate Systeme? Sind die an die Länderinfrastruktur äh angeboten? Also du kannst dir etwa vorstellen, dass du mindestens für jedes Bundesland schon mal eine separate Lösung hast, die in keiner Form direkt vergleichbar ist mit irgendeiner anderen Lösung und einem anderen und das betrifft jetzt erst mal nur die Impfzentren.
Wo bisher ein Großteil der Impfung gemacht wurde, aber eben auch nicht alle. Was die mobilen Impf-Teams betrifft,
habe ich gehört, das kann ich jetzt mit keinem Link bestätigen, aber das sind so Informationen, die mir zu mir gebrochen sind. Das ähm,
da eigentlich fast überhaupt nicht ordentlich dokumentiert wurde. Also, dass dass die selbst dass da sozusagen überhaupt gar keine äh richtige Datenbasis gibt
für all die Impfungen, die da durchgeführt wurden. Das heißt, da ist im besten Fall, im besten Fall ein Impfausweis, äh korrekt ausgefüllt worden. Und ich kenne auch viele Fälle, wo das nicht stattgefunden hat, auch in Impfzentren
Sind teilweise nur irgendwelche A4-Blätter ausgedruckt worden. Das ist dann noch nicht mal dieser WHO äh Ausweis, in denen das eingetragen wurde.
Und dann hast du noch einen komplizierteren Fall, nämlich die Hausärzte. Bei den Hausärzten ist es einfach so, die melden das auch nicht,
sondern die melden nur am Tag der Impfung.
Über so ein Onlinesystem bei der KV, also wenn ich KV sage, mache ich kassenärztliche Vereinigung, wo dann auch nochmal
nochmal eine separate Bubble hier übrigens aufgeht mit Privatärzten, die ja derzeit noch gar nicht äh impfen und in Zukunft auch noch Betriebsärzte, die es demnächst noch dazukommen. Aber bleiben wir erstmal bei den normalen Hausärzten, die an die KV angeschlossen sind. Also die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung unterstützen.
Am Ende des Tages lohnen die sich da ein und sagen wir haben so und so viele Leute mit diesem Impfstoff geimpft das erste Mal und so und so viele Leute mit diesem Impfstoff geimpft das zweite Mal.
Rittern. Das ist die Information, die dazu führt, dass wir aufm Impf der Sport sehen, in etwa, was so passiert ist.
Aber es geht nicht mit, hier sind diese Personen mit Name, Geburtsdatum, Alter, äh haste nicht gesehen, mit dem Impfstoff ist heute das erste oder zweite Mal geimpft worden. Diese Information,
fließt er nicht. Die steht natürlich schon irgendwo, nämlich in der Regel in der Praxissoftware, dieser Hausärzte.
Derer gibt es viele und keine Praxissoftware heutzutage hat ein wirkliches Impfmodul,
Wo man mal eben anklickt mit okay äh erzeugt mal ein digitales Zertifikat mit unserem äh,
Ärztezertifikat, wo in dem Moment ja im Prinzip der die Ärztin selber noch ihre Chipkarte immer rein,
stecken müsste in dem Moment, wo dieses Zertifikat ausgeführt wird, um diese Signierung vorzunehmen, weil es ja letztlich die Ärztin ist, die das macht. Und äh diese Software existiert nicht. Es gibt noch nicht mal.
Das jetzt an, ein bisschen anekdotische Evidenz, die ich hier habe. Ich habe halt mal so äh rumgefragt. Wir hatten auch im Clubhaus eine größere Diskussion, wo verschiedene Leute, die auch solche Systeme betreuen, auch
programmieren und so weiter, die mehr oder weniger alle unisono gesagt haben, so eine Software, so ein Modul in diesem dieser ohnehin äh üblicherweise recht grauenhaften,
Praxissoftware, die mir mal eben alle Impfungen anzeigt, gibt's nicht
das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als so ein Abrechnungsschlüssel in der einzelnen Patientenakte. Das heißt, du brauchst nur Funktion, die sagt, geh mal alle Patienten
durch und guckt mal in der vollständigen Historie, ob da irgendwo dieser Schlüssel für Impfung ist und mit den anderen Mittagdaten und sammelt das mal ein und dann machst du daraus mal jetzt irgendwie eine Vorlage, um daraus dann Bike, digitale Zertifikate zu machen
Und selbst wenn's das gäbe, ist dann die nächste Frage, wie kommt dieses digitale Zertifikat in die App,
Wie kommt das zu diesen Personen? Wie soll das verschickt werden?
Hat jeder Patient eine E-Mail-Adresse mit irgendwie Public Private Key Schlüssel kommen die dann alle vorbei mitm USB-Stick oder mit ihrer App und übertragen sich das dann per Bluetooth oder was? Also.
Das ist ein Projekt.
Das sehe ich nicht. Die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man tatsächlich im Prinzip alles machen könnte, ist, die Abrechnung, die letzten Endes über die Krankenkasse läuft, weil was natürlich die Ärzte auch machen, ist.
Impfung abrechnen. Das ist jetzt wirklich die konkrete, auf die Patientenbezogene Abrechnung, weil die wollen ja auch Kohle dafür haben und tatsächlich gibt es diese Meldung, die geht dann auch an die KV. Da steht drin,
Versicherungsnummer sowieso wurde eine Impfung gemacht mit den und den Mitarbeiterdaten.
Oder kann nicht ausreichen für diese Zertifikat. Das kann ich nicht sicher sagen. Sagen wir mal, es reicht. Dann.
Landet diese Information dort. Aber die landet auch nicht an dem Tag dort, sondern die Abrechnung in Deutschland ist quartalsweise. Das heißt, wer am ersten April geimpft wurde,
wird Ende Juni dieser Datensatz an die KV übertragen. Das geht dann ins Rechenzentrum
machen dann erstmal die Abrechnung für die Ärzte, das dauert dann auch in der Regel nochmal ein paar Wochen, dann geht diese Information natürlich an die Krankenkassen, die müssen das alles noch absegnen. Und erst dort bei der Krankenkasse gibt's diese Verbindung von,
Versichertennummer, die die Ärzte gemeldet haben zu der tatsächlichen Patientin. Jetzt erst in diesem Moment.
Vier oder fünf Monate nach der Zweitimpfung,
landet bei einer Krankenkasse das erste Mal die Information, dieser Patient, mit dem und dem Geburtsdatum hat eine zweite Impfung erfahren.
Wo ein digitales Zertifikat theoretisch erstellt werden könnte von dieser Krankenkasse, was dann aber immer noch nicht in deiner App ist,
Mit anderen Worten, dieses Bootstrepping, alleine.
Für die privilegierte, verhältnismäßig privilegierte Situation in Deutschland, die immer noch schlimm genug ist, dauert mindestens,
halbes Jahr,
wenn alles super funktioniert und all diese Systeme da sind und jede Praxissoftware vielleicht auch noch aktualisiert wurde, um es irgendwo hier bisschen besser zu machen. Das muss alles koordiniert werden, das muss alles irgendwie funktionieren.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir in diesem Jahr,
wirklich mit so einem digitalen Coronaausweis in der EU rumfliegen,
der uns irgendwie die Türen öffnet, den ich auch durch diesen gelben Lappen geöffnet werden kann, weil alles andere einfach.
Praktisch ein Projekt ist für mindestens ein halbes Jahr.
Und ich sage nochmal dazu, ich glaube, also die haben jetzt heute ja wieder ich äh die ähm sogenannten äh Lockerungen für Geimpfte jetzt schon äh entschlossen
Ja? Oder beschlossen.
Ja
Wo es um also wo es darum geht im Prinzip Geimpfte können sich dann in ungegrenzter Menge gemeinsam aufhalten.
Das sind.
Sogar zwei Ungeimpfte dabei haben.
Das sind alles Heilsversprechungen.
Keine Halsversprechen, das sind einfach nur Regelungen, die jetzt halt gelten. Gelten.
Ja, dir aber keiner, ja, aber die keiner überprüfen kann, faktisch.
Das ist doch genau das Problem.
Ja, das ist das Problem, deswegen sage ich es, es ist ein reiner Heilsversprechung. Es sind reine politische Signale, die sagen, alles wird gut. Ihr kriegt eure Grundrechte wieder.
Ja, also ich habe mit dem, ich habe ja gar nicht ein Problem.
Damit, dass man dafür sorgt, dass viele Leute geimpft sind und wenn die Situation wieder normal ist, man dann auch ein normales gesellschaftliches Leben wieder ermöglicht, womit ich ein Problem habe, ist, dass ähm.
Teilweise mit Leuten spreche, sehr interessant, ja? Äh die sagen, sie kennen eigentlich keine Ungeimpften mehr.
Wo ich auch sage, ach, das ist ja na dann,
Na dann, so hast du äh so ich auch gesagt, da hast du mal bitte auf diese Prozentzahlen hier geschaut so, ne? Dann kannst du ja mal sehen, äh ne
we are one percent oder was, ne? Also es gibt halt einfach Unmengen an nicht geimpften Menschen und es wird auch noch sehr lange eine ganze Dicke Anzahl umgeimpfter Menschen geben. Und wenn wir,
Klar, wir steuern jetzt schnell darauf zu mit dieser einen Million Impfung am Tag. Das ist eine eine ordentliche Rate, ne.
Aber die reicht nicht aus, dass es hier nicht noch so zu richtig Reibungen kommt. Wenn du,
hier massive Unterschiede zwischen den Geimpften und den Ungeimpften machst. Und das wird nicht passieren. Es also das wird nicht passieren können, weil da bricht die Zivilisation auseinander,
Wenn die hier also es gibt ja auch dann natürlich, ne, die Apokalyptiker, die sich irgendwie vorstellen, hier rennen dann demnächst die,
Polizisten mit den Maschinenpistolen und den Gasmasken durch die Gegend und scheuchen die Ungeimpften weg oder so. Das ist ja das ist ja auch Unsinn. Das ist ja auch.
Und wir sehen ja vermutlich gerade jetzt schon irgendwie erste Impfeffekte, zumindest kann sich keiner erklären, warum gerade die Zahlen runtergehen.
Mit anderen Worten diese nach all diesem, was was diese Gesellschaften jetzt mitgemacht haben, werden die größere ähm,
Unterschiede zwischen Geimpften und Ungeimpften nicht mehr aushalten.
Also das wird das wird das werden wir jetzt nicht auch noch mitmachen. Und das heißt, ähm letztendlich wird eine wird eine eine Lockerung für Geimpfte,
entweder äh nur gewaltsam oder besondere Vorteile für geimpfte wird man nur gewaltsam äh aufrechterhalten können.
Ähm über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Und äh was die hier bauen, mit hier schnell Pipip Check und so weiter, das ist halt äh das ist.
Steuert halt genau darauf hin. Und die Lockerungen steuern daraufhin. Also aber sie werden das nicht äh aufrecht erhalten können mit anderen Worten, werden sie einfach sagen, alles klar. Dann lasse jetzt hier locker genug machen.
Ungeimpften, die Seuchen dann mal eben schnell durch. Das ist dann eben so. Das bisschen Long-Covid ist ja dann auch nach der Wahl im September.
Ich meine äh die Motivation,
eines solchen Impfnachweises kann ich ja irgendwie auch gut nachvollziehen. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt um kurzfristig das eigentliche Problem zu lösen, was so viel heißt, wie Reisen in Europa, ja? Beziehungsweise ein Reisen nach Europa, vielleicht auch das.
Wird sich damit nur sehr begrenzt erschlagen lassen, mag meiner Meinung nach hier und da, irgendwann einmal so im Herbst, vielleicht zum Einsatz kommen.
Tim, ich sehe das, ich sehe das, ehrlich gesagt, ganz anders mit diesem also du hast jetzt schon gesagt, welche Probleme es gibt für diesen digitalen Impfpass, dass man den einfach bekommt.
Und da rieche ich doch schon ein Geschäftsmodell. Und das wird dann ganz einfach dann kostet,
digitale Impfausweis, den brauchst du ja im Zweifelsfall nur für
für deine Reisen und sonst was, dann kostet der eben fünfunddreißig Euro. Du hast ja schon die scheiß Impfung kostenlos bekommen, du undankbares Arschloch, dann kannst du doch jetzt fünfunddreißig Euro mal eben fürn, für den digitalen Impfpass äh bezahlen, an, an die Deutsche Telekom. Ist doch in Ordnung.
So das löst all diese Probleme.
Ja, es hat wahrscheinlich schon auch ein bisschen was mit äh Geld zu tun, weil letzten Endes um um so einen digitalen Nachweis ähm machen zu können, muss so im Prinzip so einen mehrstufigen Prozess äh triggern, ja?
Arzt muss es bescheinigen. Nochmal, dann nimmst du diesen Impfpass und dann gehst du zu irgendeinem Ort X und dort wird dir dann dieses digitale Ding machen.
Das macht die Post mit Post-Ident!
Irgendso ein Quatsch auf jeden Fall. Aber dass sich das in Deutschland diese Trennung auch nicht durch, deswegen sage ich auch Heilsversprechen
Ja, ich glaube, das ist einfach ein ein, ein, ein, ein politisches Argument zur Beruhigung der Leute, die irgendwie sagen, oh Gott, ich muss doch meine Grundrechte wiederbekommen, ich bin doch geimpft,
Das ist sozusagen
diese Gruppe, die sagt, jetzt habe ich ein Jahr lang die Füße stillgehalten, jetzt habe ich mich hier äh so jetzt jetzt bin ich sogar gechippt jetzt muss ich doch wieder ins Kino. Und für die gibt's jetzt dieses Heilsversprechen. Das Heilversprechen heißt
der Impfpass. Blockchain und so weiter, ne. Dann ist ihnen aufgefallen
ach gucke mal, digitaler Impffass, das hatten wir auf der EU-Ebene sowieso geplant, dann ziehen wir das jetzt auch jetzt mal schnell vor und dann machen wir hier unsere Green Card, damit können wir dann so bestimmte kritische äh Transaktionen von Menschen innerhalb von Europa damit irgendwie auch regeln
So. Das wird jetzt alles angestritten aus den genannten Gründen wird's lange dauern,
für den Sommer, um den es jetzt eigentlich politisch im Wesentlichen geht, wird das Ganze schon daran scheitern, dass die Leute einfach, die in Urlaub fahren, die haben Kinder.
Kannst du nicht impfen vor, na ja, wenn wir Glück haben Juli, August, September,
So, das heißt, du müsstest im Prinzip jetzt jeden Campingplatz sofort wieder dicht machen,
Ja, wenn da irgendwie ja äh ja Camping schon, aber mit Kindern, nee, die Kinder müssen zu Hause bleiben. Ja, wie? Das funktioniert halt nicht.
Das meine ich, das wird einfach alles äh das wird alles in sich zusammenbrechen.
Ja, na klar.
Und das ist das, das, das ist dann das Schöne äh Privileg der äh der Geimpften ist dann einfach, dass sie, wenn der ganze Mist zusammenbricht, dass sie eben diese vierte Welle äh überstehen und ein paar andere eben nicht, die nicht äh,
nicht irgendwelche ansetzen konnten und so weiter.
Die gute Nachricht ist, dass wir der vierten Welle wahrscheinlich entgehen werden. Und von daher schon irgendwie jetzt doch alles so ein bisschen halb gut wird. Nur dass der Preis, den wir dafür bezahlt haben, einerseits zu hoch ist,
Was Kranke und Tote äh betrifft, aber halt auch, was wir an Geld bezahlt haben und später in irgendeiner Form dem Staat wieder zurückgeben müssen, wenn er's nicht hat.
Und äh dass wir den ganzen,
Quatsch, auch drei Monate früher hätten haben können, wenn wir einfach mal früh genug äh reagiert hätten, vielleicht sogar vier oder fünf Monate früher, aber die Diskussion müssen wir jetzt nicht auch noch aufmachen, darum geht's ja jetzt gar nicht. Wir haben jetzt einfach nur mal geschaut, okay, Impfpass,
Was hat das für Implikationen? Ich sage, das hat eine Menge technische Implikationen. Allein das Bootstrepping und das Ausrollen wird dafür sorgen, dass das Ding,
dieses Jahr sicherlich kein großes Thema wird. Es wird vielleicht hier und da ein kleines Thema, das muss,
bei solchen Projekten, insbesondere im Gesundheitssystem wissen wir alle, wie langsam das da funktioniert. Wir haben hier so oft über äh Digitalisierung im Gesundheitsbereich diskutiert und ich muss sagen, von all den
Digitalisierungsthemen, die wir hatten. Nirgendswo war es, so hanebüchen und haarsträubend und scheiße wie im Gesundheitsbereich. Also es das hat ja echt
toppt ja sogar noch diesen ganzen Wahlkram.
So und jetzt wollen die da irgendwie mal eben so einen totalen durch. Wir zertifizieren euch mal hier komplett äh äh durch und Pipi piep und meine App und irgendwie äh die Tore gehen auf. Das klappt ja doch selber nicht. Also,
das ist schön, dass äh der ganze Bereich ist eine enorme Beschleunigung erfahren hat. Ich höre auch so bei den Leuten, die so in digitalen Gesundheitsthemen drin sind,
noch nie so viel Musik drin war und dass jetzt auf einmal die Dinge rollen und das jetzt auf einmal richtig Bewegung reinkommen, weil es nicht nur darüber geredet wird, sondern alle auch irgendwie mal verstanden haben, wie wichtig das ist und deswegen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir hier.
Über die nächsten na, ich sage mal, wir werden so über die nächsten zwei bis drei Jahre.
Wir, glaube ich, mehrere kleinere Revolutionen sehen,
welche Rolle Smartphones spielen, was Ausweise an sich betrifft, ja, bis hin zu Führerschein, Personalausweisen und so weiter, aber eben gerade auch Gesundheitsdaten nachweisen, äh, digital und übertragbar und ebenso ähm
Privatsphäre schon wie's äh geht. Das ist ein riesen Markt. Apple ist da schon ganz lange hinterher. Der Rest wird äh dem sicherlich bald folgen. Und ähm,
diese ganzen Bedürfnisse werden sich am Ende,
ohnehin nur wieder mit den großen Anbietern gemeinsam lösen lassen, weil nur dann fließen diese Informationen auch so, wie sie fließen sollen. Aber das ist halt nichts für diesen Sommer, das ist auch.
Wahrscheinlich nichts für diesen Herbst, aber es ist das Thema der nächsten zwei, drei Jahre und wenn wir Glück haben, können wir die nächste Pandemie,
voll automatisiert irgendwie, gleich mit,
Warn-Apps am Start und also für die, für die nächste Pandemie in fünf Jahren sind wir gut gerüstet. Das dauert dann nicht mehr so lange.
Also ich bin ich äh.
Ich glaube, wir haben da einfach unterschiedliche Perspektiven drauf. Ich sehe, ehrlich gesagt, das wird einfach dann Geld kosten, den zu bekommen. Ich kann verstehen, dass du dass du davon, also das ist ein enormer logistischer Aufwand.
Es war ja auch ein enormer logistischer Aufwand ähm ähm ein paar FFP zwei Masken an die Bevölkerung auszugeben. Das haben wir auch äh relativ einfach hinbekommen,
den Apotheken einfach vorne und hinten Kohle dafür reingeschoben und,
ging das so. Also ich ich sehe diese Probleme, die du da geschildert hast, aber ich glaube, da wird sich da wird sich einfach irgendein irgendein Dienstleister äh wird das dann einfach lösen. So, das äh und und von mir aus auch gegen Geld. Ähm,
Viel mehr mache ich mir aber, also ich mache mir viel also die Fälschbarkeit wird einfach vorhanden sein und die Fälschbarkeit wird halt,
Schwierig wird's vielleicht für Flugreisen oder so, ne? Das ist ja tatsächlich dann etwas, da wird das in der internationalen Reise, wenn jetzt was ich sagst, du willst in irgendein Land reisen,
sagen wir mal, man könnte irgendwann so in irgendwie mal nach so Neuseeland oder so, ja, wo sie haben, wo die sicherlich keinen Bock haben, irgendwelche ähm.
Irgendwelche Experimente zu machen oder mit du da irgendwie äh in das Land kannst. Da wird das dann natürlich eine Rolle spielen, äh so ein digitaler Impf,
passt, ne? Ob der jetzt in in deinem in deinem Kneipen äh da sein oder im Club-Dasein eine Rolle spielt, äh in dieser Form weiß ich nicht. Aber gerade in diesem Bereich ist das völlig normal, den Leuten ein bisschen Geld für irgendein Dokument abzunehmen.
Absolut, nee, da bin ich auch ganz äh deiner Meinung, das habe ich ja auch gesagt. Ich meine, wie viele Leute wollen nach Neuseeland? Also das ist so sagen wir mal eine überschaubare Größenordnung so, ne.
Richtig, genau. Dann nimmt man denen halt die Kohle ab und der der Rest wird, kann halt drauf verzichten. Ein bisschen wie ein internationaler Führerschein.
Du musst wahrscheinlich selber noch dafür sorgen, dass du all diese ganzen Daten zusammentragen kannst. Das ist nur ein doppelt und dreifach
lässt und dann gehst du irgendwohin, wo ein Stempel draufgemacht wird und dann kriegst du irgendwie da einen Download in deine App und dann dann war's das. Und dann verlierst du dein Telefon, schmeißt du dein Telefon ins Klo und dann musst du wieder von vorne anfangen.
Ja der ist mit dem Telefon ins Klo werfen, das machst du auch nur du andauernd,
ich rege mich viel eher, ich will mich aufregen über die Ungleichheit in der Gesellschaft Tim. Und du regst dich hier über über Telefone auf die die du ins Klo wirfst?
Ja, nee, ich sage ja nur, dass alles nicht so einfach.
Okay, das war der Corona-Blog. Hm.
Aber wir sind noch lange nicht fertig.
Wir sind noch lange nicht fertig. Das äh aber wir machen's jetzt ein bisschen kürzer. Echter, ey, ich fühle mich hier die Gesellschaft aufregend, du mit irgendwelchen Computerproblemen, ja.
Das ist diese Realität, von dem man immer redet.
Okay, äh die Realität hat übrigens auch.
Den Ladefuchs eingeholt. Das äh ein Thema, was ich zumindest mal hier behandeln möchte. Ich hatte ja hier in der letzten Folge, glaube ich, schon erzählt, dass ich mit Malik Aziz gepodcastet hatte.
Ähm einige Leute haben sich da auch schon so zurück, damit sie das in die Folge so gut gefallen hat. Vielen Dank dafür. Ähm.
Malik macht unter anderem ist er beteiligt an der Entwicklung der App Ladefuchs. Und die App Ladefuchs löst ein Problem, was ich auch nicht wusste, dass es das gibt. Ähm du stehst quasi an einer ähm.
Ladesäule.
Wir reden von Elektroautos.
Genau, du hast einen Elektroauto. Also deswegen, genau, du hast einen Elektroauto und du musst ja mit dem mit dem Elektroauto potenziell an eine Ladesäule.
Und diese Ladesäule ähm,
Infrastruktur. Da gab's ja dann einmal, die haben die Leute, die haben gesagt, wir machen hier Ladesäulen, dann gab's welche, die haben gesagt, wir machen Bezahlsysteme dafür und offenbar ist es so, wenn du an so einer Ladesäule stehst, gibt es unterschiedliche Ladekarten,
die dich mit denen du jeweils an dieser Ladesäule zu unterschiedlichen Preisen dann Strom tankst.
Genau, weil es gibt natürlich den Betreiber der Ladesäule. Ja, äh der sozusagen das Ding gebaut hat und da,
quasi Geld für äh haben möchte. Aber dann gibt es also verschiedene
bezahl Netzwerke, weil du natürlich unmöglich mit jedem einzelnen Ladesäulen Betreiber, was auch teilweise irgendwelche,
hier und da ist es irgendwie vom Land und Ikea und hast du nicht gesehen, ja? Du kannst nicht mit jedem so einen Vertrag haben, also möchtest du natürlich irgendwie möglichst viele Betreiber auf einmal abdecken und dann hat sich so über die Jahre verschiedene
Netzwerkverbunde aufgetan, die aber auch alle miteinander in Konkurrenz stehen, alle völlig äh intransparente,
Tarife haben, an der Ladesäule kostet es so viel, aber wenn du in dem verbunden bist, dann ist es ein bisschen billiger, aber nur nachts und tagsüber kostet es dann aber doppelt so viel in Abhängigkeit davon, wie viel Strom da rauskommt, weil wenn das nur eine kleine ist, dann ist es billig, aber wenn's eine große ist, dann ist es auf einmal teuer
Hier zahlst du für einen Strom, da zahlst du für die Zeit, hier zahlst du auch noch wie lange du stehst und wenn du zu lange stehst, dann zahlst du nochmal so und so viel, es ist
die totale Katastrophe. Keiner blickt durch.
Ich kann dir eins sagen, das wird sich auch einfach nicht durchsetzen mit diesem Elektro. Mein Diesel, mein Diesel.
Kann ich tausend, tausend Kilometer kann ich fahren ohne mit einer Ladekarte an irgendeiner Säule zu stehen. So und jetzt kommst du.
Schlafzimmer laden.
Ja, die, dafür sind die auch so klein, dass sie ins Schlafzimmer passen, so kleine Autos fahre ich doch gar nicht.
Dein Schlafzimmer ist einfach zu klein.
Schlafzimmer, jetzt größer als deins, Alter. Außerdem hat mein Auto ein Schlafzimmer.
Ja aber wenn ich das Auto rausfahre ist es größer.
Also, genau, es gibt dieses Problem, was du gerade geschildert hast. Und das führt natürlich unter den Elektromobilisten.
Zu äh der Herausforderung, dass die ihr wahrscheinlich irgendwie so ein Federmäppchen haben, wo sie ihre fünfhundert Ladekarten drin haben und dann stehen die an der an der Ladesäule und müssen gucken, äh müssen jetzt die richtige Entscheidung treffen. Und das,
äh hat mir da erklärt, mitunter hm wirklich halt irgendwie sowas wie äh zwei, dreihundert Prozent,
wohl in Extremfällen ausmachen, die du mehr oder weniger zahlst. Ne?
Zwischen der teuersten und der billigsten Anbieterin. Und ähm dafür haben die eine App gemacht, die heißt äh Ladefuchs. Und der Ladefuchs zeigt dir mit einem Finger wischen,
welche Ladekarte du an die Ladesäule halten musst, um den günstigsten Preis für dein E-Auto zu bekommen.
Genau, in der Abwägung der eigenen Mitgliedschaften, wo du gerade bist und um was für eine Ladesäule es sich wahrscheinlich handelt.
Genau und dann sagst du, ich habe hier die Karte, ich habe die diese Generatorkarte, wie wie auch immer, so. Haben sie eine App gebaut? Klingt nach einem äh ja,
was wahrscheinlich den den Elektromobilisten für Elektromobilisten sehr interessant ist. Gleichzeitig ein Problem löst, was natürlich irgendwie ja,
blöd und ärgerlich ist, ähm.
Und das haben die wohl äh nebenher gemacht, weil der Bastian Wölfle, der da auch dran beteiligt ist, ist äh hauptberuflich woanders angestellt. Malik macht auch was anderes, haben sie sich eine haben sie eine App gebaut?
Genau, dazu muss man sagen, das ist auch so ein bisschen so diese Bubble rund um den äh
Grüße an dieser Stelle äh von uns. Die ähm sind halt einfach alles begeisterte Elektromobilisten und das auch schon lange, fahren natürlich selber, kennen diese Probleme und haben für die Community einfach mal eine kostenlose App gebaut.
Kein Businessmodell dahinter.
Die denen Geld spart. So, fertig, ne?
Genau.
Und ähm dann haben sie wohl äh.
Irgendwie sich ein neues Logo gemacht, der hat Malek ja gemacht, der ist ja der Designer da. So einen lustigen Fuchs, ne und irgendwie haben hat ihn dann ihr.
Fuchs so gut gefallen.
Dass sie sich gesagt haben, wie sehr der denn aus, wenn man den jetzt plottet und oder als großen Aufkleber ausdruckt und auf ein Auto kleben. Und dann haben sie sich ein ähm schönes Foto eines Weißen Tesla Model drei,
rausgesucht auf der Google-Bildersuche und das haben sie von einer Webseite mit dem Namen Auto Filou Punkt AT gefunden. Sehen wir so eine Webseite, da sind Auto,
werde ich da jetzt draufklicke, sind irgendwelche Autotests und so, ne? Und da haben sie jetzt dieses Bild von einem Testa Molle drei genommen.
Und haben irgendwie auf die Seite oder so ihr Fuchslogo gemacht und haben das mal eben auf äh Twitter Twitter geworfen.
Genau, Autofilow ist ein Autoblock aus Österreich. Drei Jungs, die Lust an Autos haben, haben YouTube-Kanal sechshundert Abonnenten
nicht großartig äh übertrieben, ne. Also auch eine kleine,
'ne kleine Gruppe, also haben sie sogar die URL, von deren Blog, Auto Filou mit in das Foto genommen.
Und ne, haben gesagt, hier das Bild haben wir von Outifilur hier und haben das mit dem Ladefuchs Twitter Account getwittert dieses Bild,
Dieser Ladefuchs Twitter-Account hat sechshundert, siebenhundertsechsundachtzig Follower.
Das ist jetzt nicht der absolute Irrsinn, ne? Das ist jetzt wirklich nicht ähm.
Nicht besonders äh viel. Ne, für eine, für eine App und so.
Ja und dann bekam sie Post aus Österreich von einer Kanzlei Steinmeier und aus Wien.
Und die äh gesagt haben, sie hätten auf ihrer Seite gemeint, war wahrscheinlich dann eben dieser Twitter-Account. Ähm.
Diese das Bild, die Bildrechte verletzt und es uns war, nämlich die Bildrechte von Autofilou Punkt AT, die dieses Foto gemacht hat und die Rechte an diesem Wute von diesem Testa-Modell drei hatten.
Und mit dieser Abmahnung wird ein Honorar verlangt für das Foto von zweihundertzweiundvierzig Euro.
Ähm außerdem Anwaltsgebühren plus Steuern in Höhe von eintausendzweihundertachtundzwanzig Euro zweiundvierzig und man soll eine äh Unterlassungserklärung,
veröffentlichen. Jetzt ist natürlich
so die Frage, wie wenn das Honorar für die Leute, die da abmahnen, das also diese Autofilo-Leute, die kriegen zweihundertzweiundvierzig Euro und diese Anwaltskanzlei eintausendzweihundert äh achtundzwanzig. Sie löschen also den Tweet.
Und ähm setzen sich mit einer Anwältin auseinander. Beate Hubrig und ähm.
Die stellt fest, dass diese Kanzlei Steinmeier und hier den Streitwert des Unterlassungsanspruchs auf dreiundvierzigtausendzweihundert Euro gesetzt hat. Und.
Jetzt kommt dieser Fall vors Handelsgericht.
Weil sie dann, also sie man schickt ja dann 'ne modifizierte Unterlassungserklärung, ne? Ohne Schuldnerkenntnis und so weiter und,
diese Steinmeier und klagen dann vom Handelsgericht in Wien mit einem Streitwert von fünfunddreißigtausend Euro.
Weil sie sich außergerichtlich äh nicht geeinigt haben. Das Problem ist, sie brauchen jetzt also die Beklagten brauchen jetzt einen Rechtsanwalt in Wien, weil die Deutsch ihre deutsche Anwältin.
Natürlich in äh Österreich nichts kann. Und äh sie finden heraus, dass es mehr oder weniger aussichtslos ist, sich gegen diese Klage zu wehren. Ähm insbesondere sei es mit dem EU-Recht vereinbart,
vereinbar, dass eben.
Außerhalb von Deutschland wegen einer Urheberrechtsverletzung verklagt werden kann. Und ähm.
Ja, das macht eben dieses Gericht in Wien und.
Sie werden am Ende zu einem äh zu einer Summe von dreitausendvierhundertachtundvierzig Euro verklagt.
Verfahrenskosten läppern sich und outifilu Punkt AT bekommt weiterhin genau nur die zwei Euro äh die zweihundertzweiundvierzig Euro und die Kohle.
Streicht hier, ne, diese ganze Kohle streicht mit äh Gerichtskosten und so weiter. Äh dann die Gegenseite ein.
Natürlich hätten die sich gewünscht, dass Autifilo AT den einfach eine Rechnung über fünfhundert Euro geschickt hätte und sie hätten die einfach bezahlt. Ähm.
Hohe Streitwert ist natürlich äh übel und die Abmahnkanzlei hat sich jetzt daran gesund gestoßen, dass diese Autofilow-Leute, ja, sage ich mal.
Sagten, na ja okay, wir wollen zweihundert Euro haben, die haben unser Bild äh verwendet. Jetzt ist die Frage, was was ähm,
folgert man daraus. Da lese ich jetzt einfach mal aus deren Gastbeitrag auf Netzboutique org vor. Durch die Inanspruchnahme eines Anwalts sind astronomische Gebühren entstanden, die mit der Urheberrechtsverletzung in keinem Zusammenhang mehr stehen, ne? Also hier
mehrere tausend Euro für zweihundertzweiundvierzig Euro tatsächlich in Anspruch. Auch wenn es an unserem Fall nichts mehr ändern wird, fordern wir.
Das Ende des Abmahnwesens und konkret. Erstens, Abmahnungen dürfen nur zwischen Unternehmen einer gewissen Größe ausgesprochen werden. Zweitens, es muss eine Schlichtungsstelle vor Urheberrechtsverletzungen eingerichtet werden.
Für die man keine Anwältin braucht. Drittens, Streitwerte müssen gedeckelt sein. Der Streitwert muss tatsächlich abhängig davon sein, wie hoch das wirtschaftliche Interesse der Rechteinhaberin wirklich ist. Dazu sollten, anders als heute,
vorgetragen werden müssen. Viertens, solche Auseinandersetzungen gehören nicht vor ein Handelsgericht, ja,
Sie haben dann am Ende noch tatsächlich mit dem Fotografen alles geklärt. Der ist auch äh wohl,
traurig, dass sie jetzt irgendwie da anderen Enthusiasten so einen Ärger äh eingebrockt haben. Aber es ist natürlich auch klar, dass eine Kanzlei, die mehrere tausend Euro einstreicht,
sie für dich zweihundertvierzig äh erstreitet, dir nicht unbedingt sagt, dass das für sie um.
Um einen entscheidenden Faktor äh größeres äh finanzielles Interessen finde ich schon ziemlich übel.
Potenziell damit auch hier ihrem Ruf nochmal mehr schadet als irgendwie. Die zweihundert Euro vielleicht gebracht hätten.
Also das ist ja der Kanzlei sowieso egal. Ich meine, Kanzleien leben ja von ihrem schlechten Ruf und der die Webseite hier äh ja.
Keine Ahnung, die werden, ich glaube, die haben jetzt auch nicht so viel Freude an ihren ähm zweihundert Euro. Das Schöne ist tatsächlich, sie haben ja ähm.
Eine kostenlose App für diese Elektrofahrer-Community.
Sie haben darüber natürlich äh in ihrem Podcast äh sicherlich gesprochen, sie haben da auf Netzpolitik Org ein ähm
Artikel drüber geschrieben und sie haben, das ist ja dann doch auch immer sehr schön, schon vor zwei Tagen getwittert, die Community hat es geschafft. Soeben haben wir die Prozesskosten nach Österreich überwiesen
und konnten das vollständig aus euren Spenden bestreiten. Eine große Last ist uns von den Schultern gefallen, danke dafür.
Community Roles.
Community ist äh für dich da. Das ist äh schön. Man kann auch schöne Pullis mit dem Ladefuchs kaufen. Ähm ich äh habe kein Elektroauto.
Ja, aber diese Abmahnerei, wirklich, also ich habe mich jetzt schon so lange hier aufgeregt über alles Mögliche. Wir können jetzt ja auch noch über Abmahnungen aufregen. Aber das ist halt wirklich ein äh Geschäft, ja, ein einfach ein Geschäftsmodell und
das hat nichts mehr mit mit Recht oder Unrecht oder sowas zu tun, sondern es ist einfach nur noch äh eine Abzocke von diesen,
Kanzleien, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben. Und die treiben seit Jahrzehnten ihr Unwesen.
Und übrigens habe ich das gar nicht mehr so auf dem Schirm gehabt, aber hat mir kürzlich noch jemand erzählt.
Smudo und die fantastischen vier, die haben auch ordentlich abgemahnt in Deutschland und das könnte auch so ein bisschen erklären,
Warum,
vielleicht sich am Ende Smudo für eine Sicherheit versprechende App ähm gar nicht als die allerbeste Werbefigur herausgestellt hat, weil also es scheint so zu sein, dass es da echt noch so ein paar Silberrücken gibt, ja,
die vor zwanzig Jahren mal bei Napster oder so irgendwie,
blödes äh Lied von Fanta vier runtergeladen haben und dafür empfindlich zur Kasse gebeten wurden
die das bis heute noch nicht so ganz vergessen haben. Und ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, so eine von so einer schönen Abmahnkanzlei, ne
derart ähm erleichtert zu werden fürn fürn Alltagsgeschehen. Ich glaube, das würde ich auch mein Leben lang nicht vergessen.
Ja, das kann sich alles hinten raus sehr negativ auswirken.
Man sieht sich immer zweimal im Leben. Na ja.
Sin.
Ähm,
Trump bleibt bei Facebook gebannt, hat äh deren ähm Oversideboard äh gesagt, ja, das ist ja quasi das Oversideboard ist ja so der der Weg oder der der
Der Ansatz von Facebook irgendwie seiner äh internationalen Macht irgendwie Rechnung zu tragen und den Anstrich einer,
legitimiertheit zu geben oder einer Kontrolle zu geben es gibt da jetzt 'n Artikel den verlinken wir mal hier von Thomas Rudel war das glaube ich auf Netzpolitik org der sich eben auch damit auseinandersetzt, dass.
Selbst wenn man das jetzt schön findet, dass der Trump da wegbleibt es eben trotzdem ein gesellschaftliches Problem bleibt
wenn Facebook sich quasi da,
board hat Facebook sicher auch selber ausgesucht, ne? Das ist ja trotzdem nicht irgendwie gewählt worden von den Weltbürgerinnen oder sowas. Und äh das bleibt eben von der Prozedur her trotzdem ein Problem. Wenngleich ist hier,
ähm wahrscheinlich jetzt das Problem sich jetzt erstmal als Lösung verkleidet.
Ähm.
Könnte auf jeden Fall schwierig werden äh weiter Kohle einzusammeln, wenn man nicht mehr bei Facebook äh.
Ja, das scheint äh ne, auch das, ja, ähm schade für ihn.
Wie soll er jetzt die Rechnung von von den Anwälten von Rudi Juliani bezahlen? Naja, das würde er wahrscheinlich eh nicht tun.
Nee. Juliani hat's ja auch um den steht die Sonne auch nicht mehr so gut, ne?
Nee, es könnte teuer werden, wenn erstmal die Anwälte kommen.
Also schauen wir mal, wie's da weitergeht. Ähm wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen hier durchkommen durch die Themen.
Es gibt so ein Blogpost von äh Signal Signal haben gerade einen Lauf äh erstmal dieser und die haben dann.
Quasi sich angeschickt äh Instagram-Werbung zu schalten und ähm.
Damit mal die Zielgruppen äh gerichtete Werbung ähm so ein bisschen ähm
zu präsentieren. Und zwar haben sie im Prinzip äh Werbung geschaltet, ich lese jetzt mal vor.
Pilates Instructor and you Cartoon crazy.
LGBTQ Adoption.
Das ist natürlich ein echt schöner äh schöner äh Hack, ja, einfach mal.
Das ist grandios, das ist einfach, ich feier das. Also das ist die das, dass man da da, dass da noch keiner vorher drauf gekommen ist,
dafür muss man sich eigentlich auf Kopf schlagen, ne. Also wirklich genau diese Selektoren, die quasi den Werbetreibenden angeboten werden
direkt mehr oder weniger ungefiltert ins Gesicht der Tagedroup, der zu zu werfen, um wirklich mal ganz zweifelsfrei klar zu machen und vor allem das ist ja auch wirklich geil. Du musst ja mal diesen
Satz mal so,
ne? Also Beruf klar definiert. Ne? Gut, wir wissen jetzt nicht, ob das wirklich auch immer gestimmt hat, aber.
Gehe mal davon aus, ein gewisses Matching wird schon äh gegeben haben, mindestens ist es eine eine starke Annahme, also selbst wenn's nicht zutrifft, geht's ja dann unter Umständen auch also auch wenn's nicht zutrifft, kann's schlimm sein.
In den Open Relationship. Ja. Ja, da ist halt grade keine, keine Freundin. Ja.
Netim, das heißt es nicht.
Naja, keine feste Open Relationship, was auch immer.
Okay.
Na ja
So, wir wissen, wo du bist. Okay, das ist einfach, ne? Aber dieses your internatural skincare. Ja, also wir wissen wirklich genau, wie deine Hautcreme äh riecht. Aber das Geilste ist wirklich,
Also du bist wirklich so ein Fan, aber wir wissen sogar auch, wie lange schon. Das.
Ist schon sehr äh sehr gut gemacht, allerdings äh hat nicht geklappt, weil ihr wurde ähm gesperrt.
Und.
Jetzt muss man zur Geschichte schon noch mit dazu erzählen, dass ähm Facebook sagt ähm,
es wäre hier, das wäre eher so ein Publicitys dann von Signal und ähm
bestimmte, also bestimmte Regeln, warum sie den gesperrt haben, ist nicht wegen, weil Signal da so Facebook vorführt, sondern weil äh die Werberichtlinien von Facebook es nicht erlauben, auf medizinische Probleme oder sexuell
alle Orientierungen anzuspielen. Und das hätte Signal wissen müssen. Jetzt ist natürlich wieder die Frage, warum erlaubt es dir denn dann, das so genau zu tageten.
Genau.
Und tatsächlich ist es jetzt so, also da da steht es jetzt eben Aussage gegen Aussage, ich weiß aber, wer bisher häufiger wahre Aussagen getroffen hat,
Und da würde ich jetzt schon glauben, dass äh dass es bei dass es bei Signal dass sie das schon gemacht haben, vor allem weil's ja überhaupt nichts kostet, dass äh das,
zu machen, ja? Also dieser äh ich glaube da eher die die Aussage von von Signal als die Aussage von Facebook. Na.
Und äh dann sagt der Facebook-Sprecher noch, ja die Sperrung wäre die die eine Sperrung, die man da sieht, die wäre wegen Zahlungsproblemen stattgefunden oder so. Also na ja, ich äh lasse das mal so, selbst wenn.
Also die Idee von Signal war ziemlich geil und das hätte man viel früher mal drauf kommen müssen und äh schöne Sache. Völlig in Ordnung und nochmal ja, Signal zu benutzen ist äh gehört zum guten Ton.
Damit würde ich sagen, sind wir mal durch für heute.
Wirklich schon.
Ja, ich denke.
Wir sind jetzt mal durch. Ich hab gerne die die restlichen Themen die wir jetzt noch haben vielleicht in die nächste Sendung nehmen. Weil wie lange nehmen wir jetzt schon auf?
Zweieinhalb Stunden.
Ja, das äh der hört da eh keiner mehr zu. Können wir besser für die nächste Folge.
Auch mal richtig alles rauslassen.
Ja, jetzt können wir endlich mal alles erzählen, was wir sonst nie sagen. Nein, ich möchte noch eine Stellenausschreibung kurz äh erwähnen und zwar.
Von,
EpiCenter Works. Ähm Epicenterworks setzt sich übrigens auch mit diesem ganzen Themenbereich Impfpass auseinander. Das ist eigentlich die einzige NGO,
sich da grade in dem Feld äh betätigt und guckt, dass da kein Unsinn passiert. Ähm.
Die Thomas kennt ihr, weil er öfter bei uns seit Jahren,
regelmäßig in der Sendung ist und es eben diese österreichische NGO, die in diesem sehr kleinen Land äh sehr wichtige Arbeit macht und eben auch immer wieder in
Richtung EU-Ebene. Und ähm.
Es ist eine als Verein organisierte Nichtregierungsorganisation, die Äquivistant zu allen politischen Parteien und frei vom Einfluss von Unternehmen.
Für die Erhaltung von Grund und Freiheitsrechten.
Eintritt, sie suchen jetzt eine Verstärkung im Policy-Bereich und zwar eine Juristin mit hoher Grundrechtsaffinität sowie Interesse an Gesellschaftspolitik für eine unbefristete,
Vollzeitanstellung. Der Job ist also Policy Advisor, ähm Englisch, also männlich, weiblich,
divers gesucht
gemeinsame Lösungsfindung zu den relevanten gesetzgeberischen Fragen im digitalen Zeitalter, Verfassen von Positionen und Stellungnahmen im nationalen und europäischen
Gesetzgebungsprozess aufbereiten von juristischen Texten für die Webseite des Vereins, Interviews, Vorträge vor Publikum und Paneldiskussionen, Verhandlungen mit
politischen Entscheiderinnen zu den Themen des Vereins, Koordinierung mit anderen NGOs. Konzeption und Durchführung strategischer Klagen auf nationaler und europäischer.
Ebene. Wenn euch das anspricht und ihr Interesse an Netzpolitik habt.
Gute Deutsche und Englischkenntnisse und äh ausgezeichnete Kenntnisse im Verfassungs- und Verwaltungsrecht.
Polizeirecht und Versammlungsrecht, Strafrecht. Dann ähm könnt ihr euch doch mal dort bewerben.
Einen schönen Gruß bestellen, denn äh steigert das sicherlich auch eure Chancen.
Ähm eingeladen zu werden zum Vorstellungsgespräch, sage ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Na ja, wenn du meinst, ja doch, klar.
Thomas hat gesagt, wir sollen wir sollen die Stellenanzeige hier bewerben. Dann wird er ja wohl, wenn sich da jetzt jemand meldet, wird er ja dann nicht sagen, ach nee.
Genau, aber da müssen wir natürlich auch noch einen Coupon-Code ausgeben und wenn die dann äh wirklich genommen werden, wollen wir natürlich dann auch entsprechend entschädigt werden von, na, Spendenanteil und so.
Das Gewerbe Podcast. Ihr wisst es, gerade die kostenlosen. Sind die schlimmsten.
Die kostenlosen. So, ich bin durch Tim, ich kann nicht mehr. Dann hören wir jetzt auf ciao ciao.
Dann hören wir auf. Tschüss, bis bald, Leute.